with me thank you representative uh
Veo I am present in my office and my
wife is also in the house thank you and
chairman Walsh OB present um L
30133 uh you might want to try
representative oara one more time we
know he's here but representative
oara
see online I do
too okay well in either case for the
public hearings we see him online you've
actually already heard his voice so
we'll get moving I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill
352 an act relative to the operation of
recreational vehicles on state highways
uh chair recognizes the FR sponsor
representative Lee
and actually we do need Mr
oara I just allowed um representative
lean to to
speak good
morning gu here I
am uh good morning uh my name is Peter
lechman I represent Hillsboro 24 and I'm
here to speak in favor of House Bill
352 I brought this bill forward after a
friend of mine and her family were
sideswiped by a very large RV uh an RV
that was just under the
26,000 weight limit for uh commercial
vehicles and their dismay and many
others after the accident they learned
that uh there was no requirement for any
special training or uh oversight of
anyone getting a license just a regular
passenger car license to drive such a
large vehicle so I reached out to
commissioner Quinn we had a meeting back
in January around the 25th I believe and
uh he asked that I'd get together some
information to see what would work
whether the department would be in favor
of such a move to require any sort of uh
training or at least a skill test to
operate such a vehicle so thanks to
legislative services and research they
put together quite a package that was
delivered to the Department of Safety
back in
February and uh unfortunately I have to
report that um as of yesterday I did
hear from Elizabeth over at DMV she
called triy to leave a message uh I
reached out to her her voicemail was
full so I'm not really sure where the
department stands on the issue because
so we've had not connected since our uh
discussion back in January so I did
reach out to the department Monday and
again Tuesday to inform them of the
upcoming meeting today or hearing on the
bill but again Elizabeth did reach out
to me from the DMV yesterday but we
never did connect so hopefully she's uh
part of this uh hearing but so those are
my reasoning I did provide some
documents I want to thank representative
Aaron for
um notifying me last night that uh they
did not come through hopefully Rebecca
got them through today but the types of
vehicles that I would be looking to see
that there'd be at least some kind of
skill test are the large vehicle that I
show in a one of the documents I sent
along this morning and then uh there's
also a list of states a document that
can uh has two pages that list the
states that do require at least some
kind of a skill test for uh large
recreational vehicles so I guess that's
all I have for my testimony and thank
you thank you um did you say there were
two states um that currently have these
types of
regulations uh the document I sent Mr
chairman there um I can read them off
California Illinois Kansas Maryland
Nevada North Carolina Pennsylvania
South Carolina Texas and Wyoming they
all have some kind of a skill test for
such Vehicles some have a Knowledge Test
um or an a some also have an affidavit
for the ability to operate such a
vehicle so there's there's quite a few
states that at least require some kind
of a skill
test thank you any questions from
members of the
committee represent thank you thank you
very much Mr
chair uh representative lean thank you
so much for your testimony this morning
I'm interested to know uh do you have
any kind of Statistics as to how many
accidents uh that were caused by RVs in
New Hampshire perhaps in the past three
years I do not I know that's a figure
that the department of safety has they
have uh accident records on all sorts of
vehicles but I specifically do not have
that number
thank
you representative
Donovan yes uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr lean for being here today
um are so are you thinking like this
would be somewhat similar to a
motorcycle license and there' be uh an
endorsement on the license that your RV
or your recreational vehicle pass or
something similar I would because
certainly as you probably well know your
committee certainly knows as well just
to operate a motorcycle does require a
skill set um so something similar to
that I think would be something that I
would be looking for or certainly the
committee might have even better ideas
or the department of safety but I think
at least there should be some kind of a
skill set test for operating such a
large vehicle and as I think not as a
rule but for the most part U most the
people operating these vehicles are
retired and uh again they're big and
bulky and if you're operating a similar
vehicle in a commercial service you're
required to have a license so it seems
like a uh a standard that we should at
least address that way because someone
operating again a commercial vehicle has
to have a license for something this
large but operating a large recreational
vehicle there's no skill set
required thanks for
your representative
tki thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
before we started this morning I quickly
looked into motor vehicle definitions
for recreational vehicles and thought I
found it well I did find it um in RSA
259 colon
84 um DOA but then I'm looking up at
your bill and it has a definition in RSA
26-
i1 uh number eight and they're very
different well not very different but
the one cited in your bill is under Park
and Parks and Recreation and it's seems
much more
detailed the first one that I found is
in motor vehicle um statutes and it's
pretty simple um and it says
self-propelled or towed vehicles that
serve as a temporary living quarters
that's me paraphrasing and I guess my
question would be um based on your
research and how you Enis ision this
happening are you talking about also
requiring someone to get a special
endorsement when towing a third wheel or
one of those smaller Campers or are you
looking at just hitting the people who
are um driving these um large oversized
campers we lost him I think chairman
yeah I don't have him on my
screen oh no I'm gonna have to do that
again you may not have you may not be
able to
[Music]
get yeah I uh I lost I was frozen for I
don't know 30 or 45 seconds so I lost my
apologies did you hear my question
representative I heard the very end
about the vehicles being towed or the
very large vehicles I was specifically
looking for the very large vehicles that
are you know very close to the
26,000 pound limit um and and again
meeting with commissioner Quinn I
thought the best people to make that
call would be the department of
safety followup Mr chairman sure follow
up thank you uh representative lean the
first part of my question um just
pointed out that I found two different
definitions for recreational vehicles
the one that you cite in your bill is
under Parks and Recreation and is rather
detailed U but the one I found first
because I was looking at motor vehicle
law was much briefer uh 259 col 884 um.
a and um I just wanted to point that out
in case um we need to clarify uh in your
bill what vehicles we're referring to
not really a question but I think that's
it all right thanks thanks for pointing
that
out any further questions from the
committee see any n thank you
representative thanks Mr chairman and
thanks committee
members
Mr chairman y I just wanted to check in
let you guys know sorry I was late and
I'm in my office
alone I didn't hear what you said
what sorry I'm late I'm here in my
office alone okay thank you
okay uh chair
recognizes um William Collins uh
remember of the public representing
themselves in opposition to the bill do
we have H Mr Collins on
board I do not see him if you could
raise his hand if he's
there nothing I
see well if you're there Mr Collins you
will need to raise your hand in the
meantime the recognized director Ley
from the mhire Department of Motor
Vehicles good morning Mr chairman
members of the transportation committee
happy Friday to all of you um for the
record my name is Elizabeth Bei I am the
director of motor vehicles um thank you
for the opportunity to speak on this
bill the department is taking a neutral
position on this bill we're happy to
work with the committee and um
representative Lehman on this as well um
just a few questions or concerns and I
think um representative torki pointed
out one of them which is the definition
of recreational vehicles my other
concern is that leaving the policy
decision to rule making is a bit
concerning um I would look for the
committee to clarify a solution to this
whether it's an
endorsement um or some kind of testing
that would be required for this um
because I think that unfortunately
leaving it to rul making would exceed
our authority to do that or to Define
how we would um how this would be
applicable to recreational vehicles so I
would just be looking for some more
specificity in law that would then allow
us to introduce that in Ru
making and with that I'm I'm happy to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you director
oh oh wait a minute I apologize
represent
tki thank you I'm sorry I was a little
late um director bki thank you for
taking my question can you give us
another example um that may be similar
to this where um the department has
taken that role in establishing what the
endorsement might be just to understand
the role between the legislature and the
um Department of Safety absolutely we
have a number of Licensing endorsements
that you can have on on your license I
think someone mentioned a motorcycle
endorsement so again it requires that
you have that Base operator level driver
license and then you have an endorsement
to drive a specialized type of vehicle
um we have similar ones in the CDL um
licensing capacity as well where you
could have a passenger endorsement to
drive a motor coach or School Bus
endorsement so again there's a
recognition that there are special types
of vehicles that you need additional
training or an endorsement to be able to
drive
those okay thank you very much thank
you the
questions see good thank you thank you
um we'll try one one more time with uh
William
Collins don't see on the
list so with that that's the last person
I have uh to testify sign up in advance
and I see no other hands raised so I
will close the public hearing on House
Bill 352 before I do that there were two
in support of the bill seven opposed
that signed
up uh next
hearing will be at
9:30 hille what
for
e
can they hear you now I see that click
up I'm just used to doing it myself my
new
rou little walk
yeah hey we
live nobody's nobody's noding your head
we can hear you now okay
good okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 435 FN an act
relative to the suspension of driver's
licenses and creating a committee to
study the creation of a restricted
driver's license for participants in
drug
court uh recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
sites thank you Mr chairman um for the
record I am representative George Sykes
Graf and 13 the city of Lebanon New
Hampshire um just a a brief uh history
moment for the members of the committee
um this bill last year was introduced as
Senate Bill
738 and this committee the transport the
house Transportation committee spent
quite a few quite a long time trying to
um work on their original Bill uh
working with the stakeholders working
with the uh State Superior Court and so
on and at the end of the day we came up
with a um a bill which we am the amended
version went to the house and was and
was passed but it was lost in the
shuffle of covid last last year
um this
bill has some Provisions that I feel are
particularly important as do the
supporters so to begin with the bill is
is remove specific language to moral
impairment and turpitude when deeming a
person as incompetent to drive so that's
a really important point it also
clarifies license suspension in relation
to defaults and it limits those
suspensions and defaults for motor
vehicle
offenses only unless otherwise allowed
under law so as an example of that um in
federal law if you don't pay your child
support you can lose your drivers like
that that is not changed by this
bill um it also um would eliminate any
driver license suspensions for a person
who defaults on a court appearance or
conviction or failure to pay a fine for
all other offenses that are not motor
vehicle related so one of the thing
Prime purposes of this bill is to make
that Nexus between uh suspension of your
driver's license and motor vehicle
related offenses it also um so it does
in fact clarify suspension for unpaid
child support that's applicable under
RSA 263 56 col 56 it also eliminates the
authority to report names of persons
whose driver's license privileges are
suspended because of non-payment to a
consumer reporting
agency um one of the conflicts that we
see from existing uh rsas is that if you
don't pay a bill that reported under the
consumer uh reporting agency it may be
because you don't have enough money
obviously and yet if you lose your
driver's license your ability to
continue to work and ultimately pay
those those bills is a real problem and
finally it establishes a study committee
as opposed to instituting a a driver's
license for uh persons who are uh
involved in the drug court so for all
those reasons and many more I would urge
the committee to support this Bill thank
you thank you questions M of the
committee
represent thank you Mr chairman
represent Sykes just to confirm is this
is the exact wording of the bill that
the committee passed out in a positive
um vote yes thank you for the question
representative tki this is the exact
vers verion that we ultimately passed
out of the transportation committee and
out of the house last
year thank
you any further
questions
finish um seeing none thank you very
much representative thank you Mr
chairman
CH recognizes Katherine Cooper uh from
representing the hire Association of
criminal defense
lawyers
supp um thank you very much Mr chairman
and members of the committee can you
hear me can thank you um I'm calling in
today in support of this bill on behalf
of the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers um I don't
appear very often in front of your
committee and I would like to briefly
just explain that we represent U more
than 250 New Hampshire attorneys who
include the practice of criminal defense
as at least part of their work um we're
also a little unique as a professional
association in that we don't really
advocate for our members we advoc
Advocate on behalf of the public so even
if something's kind of bad for business
um if it's good for the citizens of the
state we'll support it and that's part
of the reason that we support this bill
um I think that this bill will correct
some significant flaws in in using the
the system of licensed suspensions um to
keep people trapped in a cycle of
poverty um because of the nature of our
state it's so important for people to be
able to drive and um it makes sense to
suspend licenses when there's a
dangerous driving um you know when
people are engaging in dangerous driving
or have become fit to drive but it
shouldn't be used um as a tool to try
and control people and other kinds of
behaviors that are not actually directly
related to driving so we absolutely
support that um I do have one request in
the second provision that deals with
drug court and that would simply be that
um a seat be added for the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
um there is a seat there for public
defenders but I will say that our
membership includes representation of a
much broader scope of the
citizenry and um I think that that the
drug courts um and also driving in
general um it would be beneficial to
have one of our experts who works in the
drug courts and also works um on driving
laws for usually decades um to be able
to offer their expertise as well so we
would just request that we be added to
that and I I have to admit I completely
missed this bill last year I would have
asked sooner um but uh given the chance
now I'll just make the the request today
so thank you very
much okay thank you any questions from
any the members of the
committee seeing none thank you again
hey thank
you chair recognizes B chair um I think
I'm pronouncing that right member of the
public represent themselves in
support you see
him yeah I just promoted
him need to
unmute there we go
um my name is bz Sher I'm a sometimes
known as Albert um I am a professor at
UNH law I've been uh in the criminal
working in the criminal justice system
either as a public defender or a law
professor for the last 40 years um I uh
I was one of the stakeholders involved
uh in conver the bipartisan discussions
last year uh in the that that that
produced this bill they were they were
very significant discussions with lots
of changes uh and they were bipartisan
uh uh bipartisan discussions um the bill
uh just to uh uh uh uh small correction
the bill last year that was before the
committee was HB
1667 um that's the bill that uh the
committee work and and eventually it was
passed with uh I believe a unanimous
vote of the committee um and uh got lost
in the co uh mess um I'm gonna I I'll
I'll try and be really brief uh I know
the committee's got business to do I
think you know at the core of this bill
are is two things one uh put aside those
who have engaged in motor vehicle
offenses and who Merit uh uh perhaps
Merit a removal of their suspension of
their license while those charges are
pending for everybody else it just is
not common sense to if we want to
encourage people to pay Their fines and
to uh show up for court to take away
their driver's license making it harder
for them to go to work so they can pay
Their fines and making it harder for
them to go to court because they don't
have a license it's the kind of
imposition imposition on their ability
to do what we want them to do that is
inconsistent with uh moving things
forward in a positive way I mean that's
the essence of this bill uh you you want
people to show to court so you're not
going to take away their driver's
license you want people to pay Their
fines so you're not going to make it
harder for them to uh uh to go to work
uh that's the essence of this bill um
and uh others uh have talked or uh
representative syes has already talked
about some of the details um the last
the the uh drug court uh the special
what we call the uh special driving
privileges for drug court study
commission know I've talked to a number
of Superior Court judges who are in
charge of drug courts around the state
uh and they all would like to facilitate
the the people who are actively
participating in drug court facilitate
their engaging in the kind of conduct
that helps them in their recovery that
is showing up for appointments medical
therapeutic appointments showing up for
their job showing up for drug court it's
particularly important in rural counties
like chesher and the northern counties
drug courts have been very successful
but it it it it's really an imposition
for individuals who are working hard and
actively and positively involved in drug
court uh to uh to do the kinds of things
that everybody wants them to do when
they don't have a license um so uh we we
all the stakeholders recognize that
crafting an appropriate license for
these people is a complicated matter uh
involving any number of stakeholders
therein lies the study committee rather
than trying to craft in legislation the
the the the uh bounds of that kind of
license uh with that uh more than
willing to entertain any
questions thank you very much I do see
one question representative Aaron thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr sherff for
uh coming to testify today I'm wondering
if you know uh of any statistics which
show um the percentage of license
suspensions happening because of driver
infections versus any other
issues
where I appreciate your question thank
you it's a good question um I last year
I tried to figure that out I tried to
reach out I reached out to the court
system they don't keep those kind of
Statistics uh and uh we tried to see if
we could get those kind of Statistics
from uh motor vehicles and that uh was
not it turned out not to be possible
from my years of practice and my uh you
know anecdotal conver conversations with
people uh in the system uh clerks and
judges uh particularly Circuit Court
judges my pretty strong sense is that
the huge majority of fines that aren't
paid are for motor V relatively minor
Motor Vehicles
offenses um which are not excluded from
uh this uh Bill those those are still in
place so I guess uh another way to put
it is uh I don't think there's going to
be a a major Revenue reduction by virtue
of this passing because those people who
are you know out ofers who are not
paying their speeding tickets just as an
example you um uh they don't they don't
they don't they they are Exempted from
not having their license suspended their
license if they don't pay their speeding
ticket will be suspended and more
importantly for for the court system the
court system will be able to threaten
them which is the most effective thing
with these motor vehicle scoff laws the
court system will still be able to
threaten them with the loss of license
if they don't pay their fine and so
that's still in place so again I can't
give you uh statistics I don't know if
they're obtainable given the uh court
system doesn't uh is not a data
collection system it's a uh it's a case
management system uh but I'm pretty
confident saying that the huge majority
of uh unpaid fines are in uh motor
vehicle offenses if that I hope that's
helpful to you
representative okay thank you for your
answer any further questions from the
committee seeing on thank you very much
you're
welcome chair recognizes Jean husr from
the ACLU New
Hampshire in support of the
bill asking for three
minutes thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee good morning my name is
Jeanie hesa and I'm the political
director for the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire I
really appreciate the opportunity to
testify today on HB 435
uh like the previous witness we strongly
supported this bill last year and were a
part of the really intensive committee
deliberations that happened about it um
and we're really happy with the bill
that the committee ended up producing um
and it as has been noted it passed the
committee on 20 to zero it passed the
house on Voice vote uh and we think it
would have actually repeatedly passed
the house on Voice vote but for covid um
I do want to note this bill is actually
a continuation of this legislature is
really great
bipartisan work over the past few years
to end debtor's prison to to create a
justice system that is no longer two
tiered based on income so often um in
past years your experience in the
justice system depended on your income
if you were wealthy you could afford to
get out of jail you could afford fines
you could afford to do all sorts of
things and if you were lowincome you got
hit with penalties and fines and fees
and you ended up uh in jail pre-trial so
this legislature passed uh legislation
related to debtor's prison to make sure
that people could not go to jail for a
failure to pay a fine um in 2019 the
legislature enacted legislation to
prevent the government from charging
people for the cost of their
incarceration um we've made some really
great reforms and we see this
legislation as a continuation of that
the the purpose of this bill to make
sure that people do not suffer because
of their income um this New Hampshire is
a rural State there's a you know we
always joke in New Hampshire that
everything is an hour away that's an
hour of driving if you can't drive in
this state you you probably can't get to
work it's going to be it's it's
difficult to go to the grocery store
right now you probably can't get
vaccinated if you're not able to drive
um and when you suspend a
license the the real harsh reality is
that people typically Drive anyway
because they have to again they have to
get to work if you want them to pay off
the fine they need a source of income if
they want to feed their family they have
to be able to drive to the grocery store
and so when you suspend a license what
happens is people end up driving on a
suspended license which actually then
risks them getting arrested for driving
on a suspended license and they actually
could face incarceration for that and so
often when you suspend a license you're
kind of sending somebody into this
downward spiral um of fines and fees and
again it could result in
incarceration and so we're really trying
to create a system where it doesn't have
these really harsh collateral
consequences for people who are
lowincome and may struggle to pay a fine
or a fee and and so we really commend
this committee again for all its work
that put into this bill last year um and
and we hope to see it finally advaned to
the Senate this session and I'm happy to
answer any
questions very much representative
pataro thank you Mr chair and um thank
you uh Miss rasa for uh coming here to
testify my question is um if the court
imposes a fine and if
um if the uh the defendant of a better
term they can prove um that they have
difficulties paying or whatnot can they
work with the court to for example set
up some sort of payment
plan I I believe in theory they can um
and I think that's a good question and
and it actually gets to something else
which we talked about at length last
year right which is the reality is like
suspending sentences can't may be
effective um because it's an infliction
of pain right you are inflicting pain on
some somebody you're inflicting hardship
on somebody uh and the struggle that we
would say is you know there are some
really effective policies out there if
you wanted to force Somebody To You know
spend the money that they would
otherwise spend on rent paying off fines
and fees you can threaten them with
house arrest you could threaten all
sorts of things that would probably be
effective but it doesn't make for good
policy and that's our argument here is
you know suspending a license might be
effective in certain circumstances but
it's a really harsh penalty that can
affect somebody's ability to take care
of their family to pay rent to do all
sorts of other things um so I know I'm
going off a going off a little bit from
your question um but yes I I do think
there are ways to work with the courts
however I don't think everybody is
necessarily informed of that or able to
take advantage of it and there are
certain people especially right now
we're in we're in the midst of a
pandemic when a lot of people have lost
job and have no money um and so their
ability to pay any kind of fine right
now is pretty
impaired thank you very much thank
youa did you still have a question no
okay any further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you see a few hands up
uh chair recognizes Alex
Cal hi can you all hear
me if I can get you to state your name
for the record and who you may represent
hi uh Alex cassal I work for the
judicial branch I am the uh Statewide
drug offender program coordinator and uh
thank you Mr Mr chairman members of the
committee um so I'm here on behalf of uh
the drug courts and uh judge Neta who
wasn't able to to be here so we
understand the the bill and uh we were
involved in the in last year before
covid hit we we went to the hearings uh
on that and so we we feel that the um
we're we're really neither like for or
against it um you know we we are in
favor of a study committee because
there's a small handful of states that
do have similar legislation like this in
place um so we can learn and talk to
them uh and find out what's working what
doesn't and um I know that driving for
uh individuals that are in a treatment
court is difficult especially the ones
that are coming out of jail or prison
they don't have employment they don't
have a car they don't have a license uh
it might be difficult for them to obtain
that um so we're we're definitely open
to the idea of a study committee to find
out if this is uh something that we
should that we should do in New
Hampshire and uh my testimony was short
but I will answer any questions that you
guys may have on uh the drug courts
themselves or any kind of difficulties
that participants might have while
they're in the program thank
you questions from the committee
repres thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question can you just give
me um a little more information when a
participant goes into drug court um I
assume it's not always a given that they
lose their license but would can you
give us a little feedback on the
participants and their driving
privileges when they come through your
program sure uh thank you for your
question so uh participation in the
program doesn't uh doesn't take
somebody's ability to drive or give them
the ability to drive if they've already
lost their license for previous offenses
or fines um then then then that's just
the case and we try to work with them uh
at the beginning stages they they
probably have to go to I'd say anywhere
from 8 to 10 different appointments on
any given week whether it be counseling
or Court B management or drug testing so
there is a lot of back and forth you
know driving around and and you know
like like a previous person had said you
know everything in New Hampshire is
within an hour or two of each other but
you do need to drive especially if you
live in the Northern country like in
Coos County and uh Carroll County and
Grafton County where we do have drug
courts you know to get from one place to
another just if you live in Berlin and
you need to get to court you that that's
about an hour drive and so if you don't
have a license it can be it can be
fairly difficult um so we do try to set
up other things to to help people out
that don't have licenses um but there
are a lot of obligations um if they are
on Medicaid they can uh get a ride to a
medical appointment through their their
Medicaid and have that be covered um but
if it's a non-medical appointment like
Court then they can't
um so you know we try to have recovery
coaches or maybe case managers be able
to give them a ride and that's not
always consistent across the state
across the board because of availability
and Staffing and and things like that so
when somebody comes in it's very intense
as they move through the program they
have less and less obligations with the
program and at that point they should be
looking towards um you know full
fulfilling meaningful employment um you
know once they're coming into counseling
once or twice a week as opposed to three
or four times a week so the program
itself can last anywhere from 12 to 18
months and longer if there are a couple
of relapses uh throughout the way uh
that might delay you know program
progression so it's it's a lengthy
program and there's a lot of
obligations thank you very much you're
welcome representa thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Cel for taking my
question I'm interested to know for any
of the uh programming that you do is any
of it available via remote um
attendance uh thank you for the question
so uh before the pandemic hit there was
some remote counseling that was
available mainly in the northern C uh
country you know Coos and Carrol
counties and in Grafton County uh once
the pandemic hit all of the courts and
programs transitioned over to uh you
know tella health and and remote Court
hearings as the summer months came up
Came Upon Us and the and the pandemic
wasn't as as prevalent a lot of the
treatment agencies started to reopen you
know following CDC guidelines and social
distancing if they had the room for it
to do inperson treatment the the one or
two things that were never U moved away
from iners was drug testing um because
you know we can can't do a remote drug
test and and then also probation parole
was still doing home visits uh to make
sure that their their house was safe and
there wasn't drugs and alcohol and you
know people that were um running from
the law living in their at their at
their house um and so what we found is
that especially early on in the program
that in-person treatment was really
beneficial versus remote treatment once
somebody's been sober for a period of
time you know having a remote treatment
uh seemed to work really well but
especially at the very beginning if
somebody's still actively using it's
really hard to do remote treatment on
that person three to four times a week
um just just to get them to actually
sign in and and participate so we the
the treatment agencies um would like to
maintain that if if if at all possible
they still do have the option of remote
Court I know some of our courts are
starting to open up and have inperson
court hearings with a very small limited
number um but they but they're going to
reserve the ability for remote Court
sessions for certain individuals maybe
if they're further along in the program
or they're working they don't have to
take the day off they can just remote in
on their lunch break or something like
that so right now I'd say it's more of
like a hybrid where there's some remote
there's some in person um as opposed to
when the pandemic first hit everything
was fully
remote thank you you're
welcome representative Stevens is that a
hand I see raised yes it
is um thank you for taking my question
uh what questions do you have that could
be answered by the the study Commission
uh the questions that I would have is
other states that have a similar type of
mechanism in place you know what's
working really well what's you know his
historically and and what uh was set up
that didn't seem to work well um I don't
know exactly all the different
components of of of what those other
states had done um but it would be
beneficial I think for me to look at
those and see you know is it is it just
fines is it fines and fees is it is
there a waiting period is there uh any
kind of clause if somebody gets their
license back but then they but then they
relapse and start actively using who
makes the decision to give their license
back if we know that they're using
heroin every day or is that just not a
non something that's not in the
discussion at all you know if they if
they meet their obligations with fines
and fees but they lose their license and
then that's suspended because of this
you know potential mechanism do you not
even factor in any kind of potential uh
drug use or or alcohol use even though
the program might know that they're
actively using so those are questions
that I don't really know the answer to
so I would be looking to you know for
the study committee to kind of explore
those thank you you're
welcome representative thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr casselle for
coming in this morning um do you have in
terms of the participants of uh the drug
Courts are there you have are you are
you aware of of their crimes and and why
they might be
there um yes so everybody that that
pleas in has to be vetted through the
prosecution office and usually also
local police so the prosecutor will
check with the local police that
arrested them to say do you think that
this person is appropriate so we we we
try to uh exclude uh people that are
just drug entrepreneurs that are just
dealing to you know not dealing to
support a habit but they're just dealing
in mass quantities we want to eliminate
those individuals and just take people
in that are severely addicted their
their crimes may not necessarily be drug
you know it might not they not be might
not be facing a drug crime when they
plea in um but it could be a crime that
was fueled from drug or alcohol use so
we're familiar with their criminal
backgrounds and the the prosecution the
county attorney in every County
typically has the ultimate veto power I
mean they would they would be able to
say to the program this person is not
appropriate I can't tell you why you
know maybe there's an active investig
investigation of other things that we
don't know about and so therefore the
the the County Attorney is really kind
of the gatekeeper to most of the
participants coming into the
programs that covered a lot thank you
very much you're welcome any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you chair recognizes
Richard hand
raised um good good morning Mr chairman
uh members of the committee my name is
Richard headed I am the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch um and I wanted we're not we do
not have a position on Parts two and
three of the bill but I did want to
testify to give some information and
background um and uh and to speak to
some of the questions that were asked
earlier the the bill itself would remove
what is probably the most effective tool
the judicial branch has for enforcing
obligations to appear in court um and to
pay fines that are in default but in
doing that I do want to make clear that
we do not simply pull a driver's license
when somebody goes into default when we
don't have that ability it's a
coordinated um uh connection with the
Department of Motor Vehicles but we take
initial steps um within our our the
Court's normal processes to get
compliance that does not have any
relationship with the Department of
Motor Vehicles or pulling a a driver's
license um if it and if we do get to
that stage where we do see to have a
driver's license um revoked it is not an
automatic process it does not happen
upon the request it is more uh a further
tap on the shoulder for the party that
is involved because they get a notice
and they say please contact the court um
it doesn't say please do pay the fine
immediately it says please contact the
court um so that Arrangements can be
made
and in and if that happens we are we are
we work very hard with parties if they
are unable to pay a fine um but we do
find or we do believe that the
obligation to appear in court and the
obligation to pay fines is extremely
important but I also recognize this
committee's uh duty to balance public
interest and public needs
but you know we do want to make very
clear this is not a a a switch that goes
on and off uh when the court uh
identifies a a party in default of
either appearing in court or paying of
fines um there's a process and there is
a strong desire to resolve the issue
with the parties uh to ensure compliance
with with their
duties um in the other aspect of this
you know if we don't have um a driver's
license tool really the only other
available tool is the Assurance of a
bench warrant uh which has its own
implications um but also does not is not
terribly effective if it is an outof
State party because that would only
really get triggered if they're back in
the state of New Hampshire and they get
pulled over um so it's you know it's a
it's not a terribly effective tool and
also has its own
ramifications and then the other option
is simply stop collecting on these which
would then have significant financial
ramifications to to the state of New
Hampshire um so I do you know I
recognize the the the balancing of
interests that um that the legislature
has to has to consider but I do just
want to make clear it's not you know as
simple you're in default you lose your
license there is a process and there's a
very strong desire with the courts to
work with parties uh to ensure that they
can uh resolve any uh past any
defaults the other point I wanted to
make and this is actually a request we
have on the bill itself uh if it is to
go forward it has an effective date of
60 days um and rate up until a little
over a year year plus I guess maybe a
couple years ago um this was a a manual
process between the court system and the
department or and DMV um that became
highly automated with our what we call
Odyssey system and the Department of
Motor Vehicle system uh we actually
spent a fair amount of time and effort
to be able to connect the two um and I
think this arose out of the the deaths
of the motorcyclist in the North country
and a desire to start having systems
talk to each other uh automatically so I
think as part of that we undertook that
effort uh and it was a fairly
significant effort um and to unwind it
is also going to be significant um it's
not simply uh a pulling a connection or
or unclicking a box um there was a a
significant amount of of effort because
our Odyssey database is very detailed
it's it has sort of crazy connections
and the process of making any changes to
it takes a fair amount of time uh and
actually has some costs associated with
it um and on top of of this bill would
be you know the hundreds of other
changes come out of any legislative
session so anytime there's a new felony
a new miss any new crime uh added or
modified we have to change your database
and it requires again a great deal of of
um not only just changing it but to
ensure the accuracy of those changes
because they drill down uh into into
various sections of of criminal
statutes um and I would just point out
that RSA 14 colon 9-a talks about um
effective dates of bills uh in that
statute says that any uh law affecting
judicial practice and procedure then
goes on or changes uh criminal
prohibitions or or civil causes of
actions should be shall take effect
January 1 of the following year so we do
ask that if this bill is to proceed that
the effective date be changed to at a
minimum January 1
2022 um as opposed to the current uh
effective date which is 60 days after
pass message um January to tell you the
truth January 1 would be very tight um
and we would vastly prefer uh later on
in 2022 um simply to make sure we get
the systems corrected uh or modified if
that's the way this the legislature
decides to go um and to give us time to
do that correctly and accurately so
there are no errors going forward with
that I'd be happy to take questions and
if I don't know the answers I'll be
happy to to try to track down answer ERS
thank
you see one question representative Eric
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr head
for testifying today uh about this uh my
question is so if someone
is has got their license
suspended uh as result of uh non-payment
of
fines and they are in the process of
paying these fines back um how does the
license get reinstated in full and is do
they even do that like when they're
partially through their payments or do
they have to wait until the the fines
are completely
paid how do how does that whole um
reinstatement work sure so part of it is
will be and I don't know and I apologize
for that but some of that's on the DMV
side but from our perspective once they
have made arrangements ments and they
they're complying we do not you know
we're not asking anyone to hold
someone's driver's license in suspension
pending all payments you know we the the
goal of um of the of the process is to
ensure they've reached out to the court
system they've put in to place either
they've pay they pay the fine uh or they
explain their absence um or they put a
plan together as to how they're going to
pay it we're done we don't you know
there's not a we're not going to hold
the license pending 100% of the payments
it's uh it's the desire that they reach
out get a essentially a new order if
that's needed um and uh exactly how DMV
reinstates I that part of it I I
apologize I just do not
know okay thank you so much see
representative kki thank you very much
Mr chairman thank you Mr head for taking
my question question um to me this sort
of
feels like a downward spiral that people
could have a very difficult time getting
out of and I know you're not the person
who might have the answer to this but
isn't it true that if you have your
license suspended there's another fee to
then get your license reinstated once
you have that ability to get your
license reinstated you know I I believe
that to be true I don't know that that's
a DMV question um but they very well may
have post suspension a a process for for
reinstatement and I don't know what the
waving option is for that and it may be
you know if that's a if that's the
concern if there is a license suspended
because of default maybe you know by
Statute you eliminate that fee to ensure
a smoother
restoration um that may be a that may be
a different type of of approach for this
type of legislation to to avoid that
downward spire viral but not take away
that sort of really the the most
significant tool that's available um to
ensure sort of compliance with with
duties to appear in court and to pay
fines so I I I appreciate your question
and it's a good one it is one I don't
you know it's the side of of the agency
that or it's within an agency that we
don't have any control
over um I'm happy to reach out to the to
the um Commission though and and see if
I can find an answer it helps director B
is on Deck so oh great then then
hopefully she'll have that answer thank
you still have a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr ke for taking my
question uh can you give me a sense of
we're talking about collecting fees here
can you give me total give me a sense of
what kind of total dollars of fines we
talk and I guess what I'm asking is how
big is this bucket in terms of you know
collecting these
fines um thank you thank you for the
question um I don't so one of the oh I
do have some numbers uh with a caveat
that I don't have a separation between
motor vehicle and non-motor vehicle so
that part I apologize on um but and
these are numbers from 2019 as opposed
to 2020 because the pandemic sort of
screwed everything up um but we were
talking total fines of about $14 million
about 60% of those were at some point at
some level of
default um so uh in terms of of those
numbers roughly 9 million and again that
doesn't mean 9 million you're triggering
a driver's license but that's sort of
they're at some stage of of a
default so it's it's a significant
amount of money thank
you one thank you I'm sorry I just want
one clarification if possible um thank
you Mr head
um when you were discussing what other
options the courts have for making
someone appear um I just want you to
clarify that because you only listed one
possible option um is there uh which was
issuance of a bench warrant um there's
got to be
other uh penalties or something that
could be done to call the person in
again it just seems that um taking away
someone's ability to work and get the
funds needed to pay the fine is just um
is a dog chasing his tail um can you
just explain again why that's the only
option possible sure so um you we do
they would already get some written
notice from from the court um they get a
written notice from Department of Motor
Vehicles that they have 30 days before
they're going to be suspended we do have
um within some defaults there's some
mandatory fines there's some
discretionary fines so we can add to the
fines but that seems counterproductive
also as as you suggested relative to the
downward
spiral um and we have some of these are
out of state um but you know um there's
not a terribly
the we don't really have any other tools
you know the driver's license is sort of
the most effective one if the driver's
license is an essential component of
somebody's livelihood which I appreciate
and certainly understand um I drive to
work you know I I get that um they what
we're asking is that they respond to the
letter and say um you know how do I how
do I manage this you know this is the
reason I can't pay okay we'll work with
them um
so if somebody has a good idea I'm happy
to listen but there you know they're
really not a lot of of uh of options and
it's not all money and and so I I just
want to make clear that part of this is
you know obligations just to to appear
in court um and that is uh an important
obligation you know we it it causes you
know if one party doesn't show the party
that does show has to reappear um at
times it it causes tremendous burden on
the on the court system on the parties
on uh on Witnesses you know it has a a a
sort
of effect um a broader effect than
simply somebody not showing up um
so I don't have a good answer other than
than sort of what I've already outlined
U if there was a better and easier tool
we would certainly use it um this has
been and seems to be
effective any further question from the
committee we are running out of time for
our next hearing and we do have another
speaker to go seeing none thank you very
much sir thank
you uh chair recognizes uh director
Blacky Elizabeth Blacky from enhanc
Department
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee again for the record my name
is Elizabeth thei director of Motor
Vehicles the department is taking a
neutral position on this bill as well we
do believe that oh can I we can barely
hear you oh I'm sorry let me see if I
can increase
my volume
here give me just one
minute is that better oh much much
better okay all right yeah there's just
a couple settings in there that
sometimes change so again um for the
record my name is Elizabeth Bei director
of Motor Vehicles we are taking a
neutral position on this bill um
believing that it is a matter of
legislative policy um I really am going
to be brief and then I'll um open up for
any questions my only question on the
bill is just some language that leaves
um some question in our minds as to what
is the intent of it um because there is
some language in here for example where
it speaks to um the fact that we can
suspend a license for someone who fails
to comply for example with an order of
the director or or a court with with on
any matter within the director's or
Court's Jurisdiction so there Still
Remains a question as to what judicial
um proceedings would result in a license
suspension as well um
similarly um there is another provision
in here that speaks or leaves that
language related to uh compliance with
an order of the director of a court so
um I would really ask that the judicial
branch looks closer and that so that we
clearly understand what would fall
within the scope of a license suspension
when there is some language related to
Court's Jurisdiction in here as well um
outside of that I will just open up um
with for any questions that the
committee might
have thank you director any questions
from the committee
yeah representative Aaron thank you Mr
chair and thank you um director
biki my question is I I had asked this
question before of another uh person I
was wondering if you knew um the
percentage of license suspensions for
drivers infractions versus say Court
findes you know something that's not
driver related do you do you know any
numbers for that um I don't have those
numbers available but we can definitely
um take a closer look to see if we can
provide those numbers to you in working
with the judicial branch as well thank
you and
followup thank you Mr chair um my
followup question is do you have any
idea what the average time is that
somebody's license is
suspended I I really don't and as one of
the other speakers testified I know that
the court works with um with their
customers to give them a number of
different opportunities to um to really
cure the issues that are in front of the
courts and then once that information is
sent over to us we also provide um the
customers with a notice before their
license is suspended but as far as the
duration of a license related to those
type of suspensions I really can't
answer that question thank you
the questions from the
committee seeing done thank you director
thank
you that is the last person I have
signed up to
speak and I not see any other hands
raised so we to close the public hearing
on House Bill
435 uh next hearing very shortly on
poville 328 at 11 no excuse me 10:30 Mr
chairman can you read into the record
the amount of f signed thank you uh
supporting the bill this is for 435
96 V is for one
neutral can you repeat that I'm sorry I
didn't hear you yep support uh
supporting
43596 there signed in uh oppos four and
neutral
one
right shut that
up
everything I don't
either
no we have
to there we
are yep live We Live
repres I'm sorry Mr chairman I a lot of
that you were muted for just doing a
sound check oh okay
yep all
right okay well all right I'm going open
up the public hearing on House Bill 328
an act relative to the application
process for driver's licenses and
relative to privacy of Motor Vehicle
records uh chair recogniz as the prime
sponsor representative
s good morning Mr chairman morning
members of the committee for the record
I am George Sykes uh state
representative for Grafton 13 serving
the city of Lebanon um it's been my
privilege to be a part of the
transportation committee I'm in the
middle like the chairman our ninth year
working on bills um one of the things
that I've been particularly proud of
over the years working with uh the
chairman with representative Smith and
other and other members of the committee
we've always managed to find our way to
good solutions to public policy that
needs some need our attention and um I'm
very proud of the work that we have done
to solve those kinds of things um during
that same nine years we've also had an
opportunity to
um examine what it is that we're
actually trying to do here in the
transportation committee and those
things are uh primarily
focused on five areas of policy one is
to improve Public Safety that clearly is
our number one uh issue next is to
provide expanded Social Services maybe
to also improve implementation of
Criminal Justice as it applies to the
transportation sector we also try very
hard to encourage the development and
expansion of improving
Technologies something that we've done
quite successfully over the years and
finally that we're also always working
towards improving Economic Development
by the tools that uh are impacted by
this
sector um so I wanted to remind the
committee of that and to point out that
um coming after me there will be a whole
there'll be a bunch of folks who will
get into the more uh technical details
of the bill um although I'm happy to
answer questions I think that you you'll
get a lot of your questions about this
bill answered uh as other people testify
I would also point out just uh for the
record too that um this bill did pass
out of committee and passed from the on
the floor of the house but then was uh
tabled in the Senate last year so we
never quite got got it finished so and
with that I'll end my testimony thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
take any questions from the
committee guess you don't need to I see
none thank you sir thank
you um before we do get started opening
it up to the public uh I have 18 people
signed
up two
testify um and if my experience with
these methods is is true and here the
hands come already it wouldn't surprise
me to see a couple of dozen by the time
we're done that being said we do have a
little bit of extra time built in but we
don't have all day so I'm going to start
out with a uh limiting limiting
testimony two three minutes a
piece I'd ask everybody uh if you have
heard the points that you want to want
to make already mentioned that it is
okay to wave your testimony I'm not
going to deny anybody but it is helpful
when we have this many people here to
test
um that being said um a lot of the ones
I
see are in support of the well no not
necessarily let me take that back yeah
we do see a mix so we'll get right
started um chair recognizes Christine
Wellington U member of the public
supporting herself supporting the bill
um and he's asking for five but like I
said it's going to be three so do we
have Christine will
good morning um representative W Walsh
and and the um committee can you all
hear me can good morning good morning
I'm Christine Wellington I'm a member of
the immigrants rights network and on
behalf of the network I sent you um a
letter and some supporting documents
that you um I hope you had a chance to
read that summarizes um the reason why
we uh are supporting this bill and we're
asking that the committee uh voted ought
to pass um I just want to start out with
just highlighting the points in that
letter uh for clarification for folks um
the first thing is immigration law is is
part of this issue we're hoping that um
that we can expand the group of people
that are eligible to apply for dri's
licenses in New Hampshire to include
people who are undocumented immigrants
now it's really important to understand
that undocumented immigrants um that's
not a criminal offense the federal
government has seen fit to make most
immigration law infractions civil law
infractions so being undocumented is not
a criminal offense and that's very
important to understand and know the
other thing is we we believe there's
about 14,000 undocumented IM migrants
living in New Hampshire these are people
who have been contributing to our
community who have relatives who are US
citizens and otherwise lawfully present
who have children in our school system
who are in sometimes essential workers
during this pandemic they pay about $77
million in taxes federal state and local
taxes um and that we we need to really
recognize their contribution and their
need to be able to to to uh safely uh
travel throughout the state uh we we ask
um that New Hampshire join the many
other states 17 jurisdictions so far who
have um decided to grant driers licenses
to undocumented immigrants um this will
remove a law enforcement burden that's
unnecessary it will increase Public
Safety by allowing um law enforcement
and the DMV to process people make sure
that they're eligible that make sure
that they know the uh rules of the road
in New Hampshire and comply with them
and take tests to be able to drive
safely um so I we we have uh reached out
to the law enforcement community and we
have received support from many law
enforcement entities and we ask you to
take um notice of that um it will also
increase Community well-being and life
um people within the Immigrant Community
including people who are US citizens and
um lawfully present are often afraid of
encounters with law enforcement um
because of the fear that people will be
seized um and so that contributes to
fear of reporting legitimate crimes and
other problems in the neighborhood and
being able to establish trusting
relationships with the law enforcement
Community EXC excuse me now we passed
three minutes and I'm just trying to be
fair for everybody okay a closing
statement that you greatly appreciate I
think I I I've summed up most of the
points I wanted to make to the committee
thank you very much I yield thank you um
any questions from any members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much um chair recognizes br Brunos SS
familiar
name um in support of the
bill hi good morning morning can
everybody uh hear me okay we can
sir okay um so first I would like to
apologize for for sending uh mass emails
in the uh the past couple of days um and
although I have provided you uh a copy
of my testimony I'm going to to deviate
a little bit from my testimony to
address some of the concerns that have
been raised in the past few years about
this legislation uh first uh this
legislation does not conflict with
federal law under article six paragraph
two of the US Constitution federal laws
to precede conflicted state laws and
laws within certain fields that the
federal government intends to occupy
there is no conflict here because
issuing a driver's license uh Falls
within the scope of the state's
sovereignty power under the 10th
Amendment second this legislation does
not conflict with the federal ID Act of
2005 under the anti- commander Clause of
the US Constitution as it has been held
by the US Supreme Court in New York
versus United States
1992 that Congress may not comen the
states to enact or administer Federal
regulatory
laws in addition under Section 202 d11
of the federal ID Act of 2005 it allows
the states to issue a non-federally
compliant driver's
license third immigrants will not use
the driver's license except for the
purpose of operating a motor vehicle
more specifically I would like to talk
about voting since the establishment of
New Hampshire as a state only US
citizens have been charged with voter
fraud in most cases the person charged
is a retired US citizen who lives in New
Hampshire and in another state which
most recently is the case of Vincent
Marcelo 65 of West Lebanon furthermore
the concern of noncitizens voting is
already addressed in several provisions
of the immigration nationality act which
effectively deter immigrants from
claiming to be US citizens for example
immigrants would be permanently barred
from receiving any immigration benefit
under Ina section 237
a3d from if they claim to be a US
citizen in order to register to vote one
must prove their identity by showing a
US birth certificate
a US passport or a US naturalization
certificate the driver's license is
merely to prove residency in the state
nonetheless I would like to stress that
for more reasons voting in favor of this
bill is the right thing to do as
thousands of lives are in your hands and
you can make a difference in their lives
as immigrants contribute a great deal to
the state's economy as the packet
provided to you by attorney chis wington
shows
thank you and I am open to entertain
educated
questions thank you sir we's see what we
can do any questions from the
committee seeing n thank you very much
thank
you uh chair recognizes uh loio
Costa in support of the
adult
are you seeing that name Mr chairman I
can't see it could be I see an alost
that could be it oh
where it's on the top top page I see I
see there we go guess that's the same
person can you guys hear me you can good
morning
oh good morning okay all right my name
is aloise yosta I'm a I'm a pastor from
the Assembly of God bethl in New
Hampshire uh I represent the
community uh as well not only the church
but um part of the uh uh the community
uh uh leadership and uh the reason why I
wanted to to to speak about this is
because I used to be a police officer
back in Brazil and I understand the uh
the importancy for the police to to to
to to know that
everyone have a driver's license in
their pocket when they stop a
person uh what they're looking for is
just the uh the uh the driver's license
which allows them to drive a car in the
roads of New Hampshire so uh we've been
meeting with all the uh the police
departments in in New Hampshire uh Mo I
mean not all of them but a lot of them
and they all agree that uh it's better
for them to have a person with the
driver's license with something that
they can identify the persons persons
with and uh and thinking about the the
community these people like it's been
said already they're part of the
community they're they have their kids
in school they they're contributing with
taxes for the state for the uh for the
city for the for the for the country
they they they're working they're
producing and they need to go to the to
the doctor's appointment they need to go
to school they need to to go about their
business and what happen is without
having any opportunity for them to have
a driver's license they're to Survivor
to survive and they they're driving
without a license this is this is no
good this is no good for the uh for the
state this is no good for the public
this is no good for
security uh of the of the state the city
and the and the individuals the the
American people so I I encourage
everybody who who's voting to to think
about those things because uh uh they're
driving on the roads without a license
it's not that not that they want to
drive without a license but because they
have no no opportunity they have no
possibility there's no fine that they
should pay to get a license there is no
open doors there's nothing there's
nothing that they can do and like I said
before in order for them to survive they
need to find a way driving a riding a
bike is not an option the whole year
because of the weather So eventually
they're going to drive
and uh and uh even even for the uh for
the National Security having somebody
with an ident
in their pocket is is is a is better to
even hold them accountable for whatever
crime they commit if they don't have
anything in their pocket they can say
whoever they are and the police is not
going to be able to to to find out who
they are they can give different names
and stuff so
me just to be fair to everybody it's
been three minutes plus I'll give you a
closing closing statement if you can
yeah um I mean I thank you very much for
the time and uh I just want to close
with the with the uh testimony of uh a
person uh in our church who is a pastor
he's a pastor but he doesn't have the
license and he was stopped by the police
the police called the uh the
immigration the immigration starts a
process there there's no hope because
there's no law to protect the uh at
least to to give him a a way out that he
can pay a fine or whatever and get the
papers so it's just something that is
complicating the family he's got three
kids and a wife and he has no way out
because he wants to follow the law but
there is no option that the state is
given to him to be right with the law so
thank you very much and I hope uh I hope
this bill has passed get passed thank
you very much any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
again chair recognizes Michael
carrian in support of the
vote I do not see hi um sorry
can you hear me can good morning good
morning everyone I'm very sorry this
computer's a little sketchy in this
hotel room uh my name for the record is
Michael kigan I am the chief of police
for the National Police Department Mr
chairman I appreciate you giving me the
time um committee members thank you very
much uh I will be brief as many of my
sentiments will have already been echoed
today what I'd like to talk to you about
is two basic points number one as the
chief of police for NASA I can also
speak for the Chiefs of police of Hudson
Hollis who you'll hear from later marac
and some of the surrounding towns
including Bedford and Manchester uh we
all feel very strongly about this uh and
so what I want to say is we as police
officers in this day and age have been
tasked with uh improving relations with
all community members it's been a very
tough time for law enforcement it's very
been a very tense time um it's because
of all those um issues we've engaged
with community members we've gotten out
we've had meetings with many different
minority groups in the community of all
different shapes and sizes and basically
through that we get to know them we get
to know them as people we get to know
them as moms and dads bringing their
kids to schools parents going to work
trying to get their uh to the grocery
store and back trying to get to the CVS
to get their kids medicin all these
things that we take for granted every
day we've gotten these undocumented
people um who can't do that or have to
do so in fear of being stopped and
arrested by us um and that's just wrong
it's it's wrong for people who uh who do
the right thing have no criminal record
are just trying to live their lives and
be productive members of society to not
be able to do so what we're asking for
is simply for a group of people to be
able to show that they are aware of the
rules in the road and can pass it
through a written test and can get in a
car with a with a certified instructor
and prove that they can drive a vehicle
then they're held to the St same
standards as everybody else they have to
register their cars they have to pay for
their licensing they have to have
insurance or they should be having
insurance so all those things uh would
help help everybody and allow them to be
normal members of society and continue
to be the productive members of society
that they are um it's it's to me it's
the right thing to do and it will save
our law our law enforcement communities
won't have to stop them and be dealing
with operating after suspension
arresting somebody having people who are
victims of sexual assault crimes not
feel comfortable reporting crimes
because they don't want to be stopped if
they're undocumented so it's for us I I
think it's a it's a
win-win situation there is no negative
the license to drive is not a license to
vote these folks can't get out and go to
the polls and vote for uh in any
elections so it's really a positive
thing to do and I will wrap up real
quick I want to thank you for your time
I will challenge each of you to go out
into your communities and get to know
some of the undocumented that work hard
and have their kids in school listen to
their stories and listen to their fears
and please just pay attention all we're
asking for is a a privilege to drive a
car legally and that's it thank you very
much for the time I appreciate it thank
you very
much will you take any
questions questions yes sir represent
flers thank you Mr chairman thank you
chief carrian for coming and speaking
with us today um I know you were trying
to be be brief but you did touch on the
fact that um the fear of being in touch
with the police could prevent someone
from um reporting a sexual assault
or some other crime do you feel that if
a undocumented community members do have
that legal license and they know that
they're not going to be um putting
themselves in Jeopardy um by contacting
the police that that would in turn um
improve um the community and the the way
that these community members can
participate um in the process of keeping
our city here in Nashua a safe place to
live
absolutely 100% I agree with that it
would give people for the most part
people um the undocumented are not
committing any crimes with the exception
of driving without a license so if they
could have that license and get to and
from work they're much more comfortable
talking to us they're much more
comfortable if they do commit a motor
vehicle violations they get stopped they
get a ticket they pay their fine like
everybody else with that Comfort comes
the trust in law enforcement that we're
there to help and that trust is what
we're working so hard and we've been
working tirelessly over the past 5 years
to try to get that trust so they will
come to us because driving without a
license isn't a big deal somebody who's
being a victim of domestic abuse or
sexual assault is a huge deal and if
they're afraid to come forward and tell
us about it we can't help them and
that's our mission and that's the
priority of our mission so it's it's
important for us to to have that trust
and that trust if it means giving them a
a a license to drive a vehicle and
that's it I think that goes a long way
to solve a huge problem for us thank you
chief
representative
cleverer thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you Chief
Gan for all your work in nashwa and for
coming to testify
today appreciate it very
much how how many interactions would you
say would
be on on average how many interactions
with undocumented do you have as police
officers during any given period any
month say so it's it's we don't
necessarily track that information uh
Alderman CLE uh sorry representative
Cleaver because we um they don't
necessarily uh we don't ask the
questions of their immigration status
when we stop them so it's hard to
document that we can usually determine
it through arrests only and and then
only by going through their country of
origin and assuming that they don't have
the license which is a lot of
assumptions but I will say this um
having worked in as for 28 years years
especially the last five years having
gotten out into the community we uh have
a large amount of interaction with them
and generally uh operating without a Val
license happens hundreds of times a year
for
us follow up please follow up yes so
what you're saying then Chief is that
the interactions with drivers is is
quite
frequent yes sir absolutely okay thank
you very much thank you sir
Phil good morning thank you Mr chairman
uh and good morning Chief thank you for
coming in I uh my my question is uh
concerning those people that you do uh
interact with um that you just mentioned
is there a way of knowing a percentage
of those that uh that carry um auto
insurance when you when you run into
them well no because right now they're
not allowed to get a driver's license so
I would imagine they can get the auto
insurance um through the registered
vehicles I don't know the answer
completely to that but that's an
assumption I have I will tell you this
if they're allowed to get a license and
do so legally they're much more inclined
to get their license uh their vehicles
registered get them inspected um make
sure it's their vehicle as opposed to
borrowing a friends who has a valid
license so there's a there's a whole
spiderweb of things that would be helped
if they just had a license to drive did
feel more comfortable obeying all those
rules of the road if that answers your
question it does thank you very
much seeing no further questions thank
you very much sir thank you everyone I
appreciate the
time our chair recognizes Joseph ocki
state agency staff I'm not sure which
one not say uh in support of the
bill I do not see him Mr chairman do you
I do not either let me scroll one more
time oh there he is I think Chief Joseph
right
there
okay Mr chair can you hear me can now
good morning good morning I apologize
for the uh issues with the audio i i two
him in a hotel room uh waiting to do uh
the final dip in the ocean for uh
Special Olympics Mega dip which is 24
dips in 24 hours with Chief pnan from
NASA so um I'll cut to the chase uh
again my name is Joseph hcky I'm a chief
of police in in the town of Hollis um I
don't want to reiterate too much of what
already has been said but I can I can
assure you that as a as a chief uh my
job is to be apolitical and I act upon
what I feel is right um for Public
Safety what's
just and uh what's in the best interest
of our state and our community since
I've been a police officer which is 20
years we have dealt with the same issue
of undocumented persons operating
Vehicles without drivers licenses a
large majority of these people are
merely from my personal experience as as
a as a patrol officer for several years
were merely attempting to travel to and
from work or were attempting to drive
their families uh to you know certain
events such as doctor's appointments or
school events um as we've heard many
times before we can't simply arrest our
way out of an issue we can't simply
issue
summons uh to navigate our way out of a
problem um and again my testimony is not
to address issues such as voting but
from a public strictly from a public
safety perspective why would we not have
a mechanism in place that allows people
undocumented persons living in the state
with a means to demonstrate that they
can safely and legally operate a motor
vehicle not only does this um uh show
that they can be proficient and
demonstrate that they can safely do so
it also helps my officers because it
provides provides them with a way to
obtain accurate information so if they
write a summons they know that the
person listed on that summons is who
they say they are um also in terms of
NEX ofkin notifications if there's a a
traffic accident we have to notify
family members oftentimes with
undocumented persons we don't have that
and it complicates things and then you
think about the revenue this would
generate for the state I mean there's
seven you know roughly 17,000
undocumented persons and you know we
know that not everyone drives but um
we're as eligible to drive but think
about the revenue that we create for the
state if we could you know uh provide a
legal mechanism for these folks to get a
driver's license so again and I'll
summarize I'm not alone in this you
heard from the Nashua Chief the Salem
Chief the Hudson Chief the marac chief
we've been working on this issue for the
last several months with Bruno and other
stakeholders we have we have done
nothing in the 20 years I've been a cop
to address this issue properly it's not
going away we need to do something in
order to address this issue and the fear
component amongst minority populations
towards po police is very real and I can
tell you that I've met with with these
communities and they are very afraid
that they're going to be stopped and
arrested and I don't think that excuse
me
Chief uh my closing is I don't think we
should position ourselves um to create
an environment where people are fearful
of us because uh we have the ability to
change something and create a process
but we just don't do it so I certainly
appreciate your time and I'd gladly
answer any questions that you or the
committee members have thank you very
much any questions from any members of
the
committee represent pataro thank you
chairman um and thank you chief for
coming tonight I kind of wanted to ask
this of your um colleague in nashille
about Hudson is a Border Town as well
I'm just I'm just curious are you in any
way obligated if immigration forces come
to you to turn over um criminals
or it seems kind of Sensational how they
portray it in the media I'm just
wondering if you you if your department
has any sort of direct contact Federal
enforcement agencies concerning
immigration yeah so I mean I work in
hollus so that it's very limited
occasions and there are very there are
very strict I used to work in Hudson so
I know it's a bit confusing but um
there's there's very strict limitations
on when and when you cannot contact UM
Federal immigration uh law enforcement
Representatives um you cannot um for
example you cannot use um um your
suspicion that you believe someone here
is here illegally or is an undocumented
person as a justification in order to
stop and detain them it would have to be
in conjunction with some other type of
uh criminal offense or motor vehicle
violation and they would have to have
some type of detainer on them or request
from a federal agency in in order to
execute on that detainer I hope that
makes sense that helps thank
you questions see you none thank you
very much Chief thank you sir have a
great day and good luck
one more to go thank
you our chair
recognizes Maggie fogy uh representing
the American friend Services committee
New Hampshire in support of the
bill hi good morning can you hear me you
can good morning good morning thank you
Mr chair chairman and members of the
committee I'm I'm grateful to have a
moment to speak with you my name is
Maggie Fogerty I'm the director of the
New Hampshire program for the American
friend service committee and I'm here to
express our strong enthusiastic support
for HB 328 and I will speak briefly
because the key points have been made
well by my colleagues but I want to
emphasize that in a state like New
Hampshire with so little infrastructure
for public transportation driving is
essential to the well-being of so many
families who need a drive to their jobs
take their children to school buy
groceries go to healthc care
appointments go to church and we believe
that there should be common sense
requirements for someone to drive safely
on New Hampshire roads that they be able
to show proof of of who they are proof
of residency and proof of Competency
through the written and practiced tests
but there's no meaningful justification
for immigration status to be a factor in
this process it simply does not pertain
to
safety uh and the current context of US
immigration law is too convoluted and
chaotic and cruel to be used as a
measure of eligibility for driving
millions of people in the United States
and many thousands in New Hampshire have
been in limbo for decades they have
every desire to regularize their status
to continue to live and work here and to
remain together as a family without
threat of separation and Congress has
failed for decades to establish a Humane
Common Sense immigration reform it is
past time for them to do so but in the
meantime New Hampshire should join the
17 other states in Washington DC to
implement a common sense law so that
people drive safely here people are here
their lives are here and they shouldn't
have this chronic stress and potential
trauma I have seen up very close I've
been visiting immigrants in ice custody
at the straford county jail since
2014 I have met fathers and mothers who
are being torn from their families um in
the events triggered by driving without
a license I met last year a man a
beloved uh multi- decades resident of a
small New Hampshire town who every year
was the clown in their fourth of July
parade and now his US citizen wife and
children are separated from him because
he was uh caught driving without a
license all of that stress separation
and Trauma is avoidable so please vote
in favor of this Common Sense provision
thank you thank you very
much see no questions from the committee
thank you
again well not an uncommon thing to do
uh chair recognizes Grace Ki
also representing American friend
Services
Committee in support of the
bill hello can you hear me can good
morning good morning thank you
hello and thank you to the committee for
giving me the opportunity to speak my
name is Grace K I am the program
coordinator with the American friend
service committee and I am from the man
I am from Manchester and have lived the
majority of my life in the granite state
after immigrating here as a toddler in
1989 I know firsthand what it's like to
live as both an undocumented immigrant
and as a documented one in the granite
state I am here in support of hb3 328
and urge the committee to pass this bill
it is nearly impossible to live work
shop or even go to school in New
Hampshire without access to a vehicle
and I know that firsthand I was in high
school when I learned that I was
undocumented and joined a community of
people who are often an overlooked but
indelible part of the fabric of the
state undocumented people residing in
New Hampshire are about 14,000 14 17,000
people as my other supporters have also
stated we are contributing members of
the state's economy and quality of life
and we are your friends your family
neighbors and loved ones not being able
to drive that even as I like so many of
my peers and my friends work to
contribute to my family and get my
education I had to do so without a
license in a state with almost no public
transportation system living in
Manchester which probably has maybe the
more robust uh local bus system local
buses only ran once an hour and there is
no efficient way to travel between towns
and cities unless you have a car so
people drive because they need to drive
but driving as an immigrant as you've
heard comes with the particular danger
of becoming criminalized for simp simply
doing what we can to work care for our
families and contribute to our
communities there is no need for this
often the only crime is driving without
a license and this bill would change
that this bill would enable people to
drive and also make our roadways and our
community safer I urge the committee to
vote a to pass on this bill which will
go a long way to making New Hampshire a
much safer place to live and work for
all who live here thank you and I'm
happy to take any questions you very
much see no questions of committee thank
you
again thank
you chair recognizes Larry weltz elected
official as a representative I apologize
with this new format I usually try to
put Representatives up early so I do
apologize I dismissed
it hello yes we can hear you good
morning yeah good morning Mr chairman uh
thank you for the opportunity to speak
in favor of this bill I
bear with me one second starting my
video I'm not sure I'm on um I'm a State
Rep from uh chesher County District 4 I
am also a the chair of psychology at
Keen State College where I'm sitting in
my office right now and I just wanted to
uh give a case example of that
exemplifies why I support this bill um
we we bring at times staff or college
professors or students from from other
countries too Keen to work here or to be
students and they have to go through
this strange and arduous process to uh
to work here and and sometimes they move
towards
citizenship um at times when we when we
use the term non-documented at times
certain visas or permits lapse and
there's certain periods of time before
they're able to secure the next level
documentation and that's often why they
called non-documented even though
they're moving through a legal process
that's on the table and uh just this
morning I was talking to a professor
here who came from
Ireland and he uh went through a similar
period where he was quote non-documented
he was unable to get a driver's license
and during that time he fell at his home
and he had a head injury and he was
confused didn't know what to do he
didn't have a proper driver's license he
didn't want to put himself at risk
for being sent back and losing his job
here at Keen State College so he um
actually got a neighbor to drive him to
the ER to take care of his head injury
so it's this sort of thing that is you
know just is a problem for us as people
go through these periods of time between
documentation even though they're on a
legal process um we also have people who
are seeking Asylum living a handful of
people here in Kean New Hampshire they
go through a period usually six months
or longer where they are going through a
legal process but they're not documented
they're unable to get a driver's license
and so we have to sort of get people in
the community to drive them to their
English as a second language class or to
their internships at local farms where
they're learning skills those sorts of
things so for that reason just again uh
like the the police chief said for
Common Sense reasons um I'd urge you to
support this Bill thank
you thank you very much see no questions
from the committee thank you
again uh chair recognizes and I
apologize also State Rep Maria
pz just did not see you
earlier thank you for the opportunity Mr
Mr Sher
um my name is Maria Perez I'm a state
representative for district 23 Milford
um I'm calling and support of this bill
one of the reason that I support this
bill is um I'm a Survivor of domestic
violence and I heard some of the police
officers say it if um someone who is a
victim of domestic violence or any kind
of violence uh if they have the
confidence they can um go to the police
and then told them exactly what they
going through um they will do it and and
I believe this bill would help to people
to have that confidence and then um feel
um more uh safe to go to the police
department without being scared to get
the Porter and the other thing that I
want to say is a lot of these people
they he there
are members of our communities they have
businesses who who are um employing some
of our citizens and they pay taxes and
then the other thing that I I want to
say um is if we pass this bill um it's
going to be revenue for our state and
it's going to be revenue for of
automobile insurance companies because
you know these people if they have a
driver's license they were GNA be able
to buy a vehicle not using someone
else's vehicle and that uh is going to
be Revenue not just for the for for us
as a state but it's going to be revenue
for insurance
companies and thank you for your
time see no questions thank you
again chair
recognizes J huser from ACLU New
Hampshire support of the
vote
iote the right
person Mr chairman um I did not ask to
speak no I looking for Genie
crry that sorry about
thata see
you she's on the list of participants Mr
chairman or attendees excuse
me may have lost
represent usually does
the she she's raised her hand
now good morning
morning thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh it's great to be
with you a second time this morning my
name is Jeanie hores and I'm the
political director for the American
civil liberties Union of New Hampshire
it's actually really great to talk about
this bill right after the last one
because it it's not an unrelated theme
which is the importance of driving in a
state like New Hampshire that is so
rural that to access anything from a job
to medical care to even picking your
kids up from school depend depends on
one's ability to drive um and again not
unlike the bill before we're talking
about putting people in a situation
where we actually risk criminalizing
them for taking care of their family
forcing people to drive without a
license risk unnecessarily criminalizing
them it is a crime to drive without a
license in this state and in the absence
of this legislation we will
unnecessarily expend law enforcement and
state resources on penalizing people who
would read get a driver's license if
they were allowed and I also I just want
to underscore what some of the previous
Witnesses said about the opportunity to
reduce the fear that undocumented
Granite Staters have towards law
enforcement the ACLU actually released a
report in 2018 about the very real fears
the immigrants have of law enforcement
particularly due to the fear of being
deported and this fear has real life
implications including deterring
immigrants from cooperating with law
enforcement or even calling law
enforcement in the event of an
emergency Daily Report noted that quote
fear of deportation is stopping
immigrants from reporting crimes and
participating in court proceedings I
think we all know that the most common
interaction with law enforcement is is
in motor vehicle context so if we
provide access to Driver's Licenses to
undocumented Granite Staters we really
do believe this would reduce the fear
that they have towards police polias and
could enable cooperation it would allow
undocumented Granite Staters um to have
more faith in interacting with law
enforcement they may call them more in
times of emergency um and we could
really build community uh collaboration
and Trust in those instances um so I
thank you for your consideration of this
bill I'm happy to answer any questions
that you may
have thank you seeing no questions thank
you again thank you
chair recognizes Mariana
Marcelino support
of
back
chair recognizes Alejandro
Yia Mr chair just promoted Mr y here he
needs to
unmute you can hear me sir you need to
unmute on your
end I have
you no we lost you can you hear me oh I
can good morning all all right thank you
so um so
um for the record my name is Alejandro
ruia from Hudson New Hampshire I am a
retired physician my professional work
has been abroad but uh here in United
States I work as a researcher and
providing training to medical and
emergency responders and basic life
support and advanced cardia life support
Mr chair and members of of the
transportation committee I agree with
the my the previous statements um so I
want just to concentrate on the medical
related issues associated with the
benefits of having a driver license
especially if we consider that many
estate residents cannot so far now they
cannot have a driver license but they
are
forcer to
drive dealing with an unconscious
patients in a hospital environment can
be a dangerous event identifying unnown
emergency room patients usually involves
assigning the patient an identification
tag with a hospital number or medical
record number still the risk of treating
a patient with no identification rise in
the absence of any formal identification
credentials like is a driver license
unanswered questions about their past
medical history and are a significant r
and post air treat to threat to the
patient
safety the pharmacy um the pharmacy
require patient
identification uh before dispensing a
controlled substance prescription a
foreign passport or consulate ID card is
acceptable but um as several times the
farm their Pharmacy put to the the
trouble uh the patients to asset foreign
documents ments like
identification um this is especially
challenging when the patient does not
have enough English to advocate for
themselves and I know this because I had
to help several times in cases like like
this where I could help still the
medication was given reluctantly by the
pharmacy
personel by registering to be an organ
and tissue donor in a driver license
more people of all ages can
donate um we need to consider that many
more donors are needed accordingly to
the United States Department of Health
and Human Services fewer than 2% of
registered donors are actually in a
position to Save a
Life B an organ donor registered in the
license is one of the greatest things we
can do we can improve and even save save
many people lives one organ and and
tissue donor can save the lives of up to
eight people and enhance lives of so
many through Tio donation a donor can
enhance countless others lives through
bone donations for repair fractures and
prevent amputations and skin donations
to heal burn patients donors can also
donate their corneas giving the gift of
sight to receive
if a patient has a driver license
Physicians have a way to inform the the
DMV when they diagnose a patient with
any medical condition that may affect
the person ability to drive safely and
also the driver license indicates if
that person needs to use glasses I don't
want to I want to send you a writing
statement that is with more information
about medical related issues but I want
want now to ask you to how to pass HP
328 and I am um um here if you have any
any question for
me
much see no question thank you again
repres sorry represent tki it just came
up thank you I apologize thank you for
taking my question um would you say that
um undocumented persons who don't have
the ability to drive are going to make
certain choices about their health care
because they either can't get to
appropriate medical care or for fear of
having to turn over a license for
identification at the physician's place
yes there is a this is one this is one
reason so many many many people who
isn't documented they end going to
waiting to go to the emergency room
there is a combination of two things one
is the uh the not access to to to to
health insurance is one problem and the
other problem is the identification also
to call Emergency Services they they are
afraid that uh when they call the
ambulas for example this their situation
or their that could be discovered and
they are undocumented and that could be
landing that information on immigration
and force personel um there is
and and and there is an issue also and
with there is the lack of um of of
driver license is in for example is in
an accident sometimes there is people
that should go to the hospital and
sometimes the ambulance recommend them
to go to the hospital and they they said
no they don't want they don't want to
they don't want to go because they are
afraid or something could happen even
sometimes people that they are not we're
not the people that were driving where
people than they just want there in the
car I don't know if that your question
thank
you you're welcome seeing no other
question thank you again
sir thank
you to call on honorable Neil Kirk next
unfortunately I think he just left see
on the list huh
he may he may return so we'll we Circle
back she
recognizes Eva
Castillo in support of
adult good morning can
you
okay my name is Eva Castillo thank you
for allowing me to speak and I'm calling
from
Manchester uh I concur with every single
word my predecessors have said so I'm
not going to to repeat that the fact is
that this is a practical matter we have
people on the road driving right now and
this is not only going to benefit those
people it's going to make us safer as a
state as a community so this is this
will benefit every single one of us I
have worked in Manchester and in all the
state of New Hampshire with undocumented
for over 30 years I I'm also a police
commissioner in Manchester this is my
third term uh I'm not speaking for the
commission but part of my role has
always been to make sure that our
community
trusts the police and I can vouch for
that fear that immigrants have of the
police because of the experiences that
we've had in our countries uh our police
officers in our countries are pretty
corrupt and bad and we have that in our
hard disk if you will so we come here
and in addition to that we have the
immigration status and uh there is
plenty of reasons to fear and many times
I have had to really talk to my
communities and make and convince them
to go report crimes or they don't feel
safe reporting crimes or fear of of
immigration and for lack of having a a
some type of identification people are
going to continue driving given what you
heard the the public transportation
system here how limited it is and this
you know many times people can most of
the time people cannot re uh
do register their cars in their names
because they don't have a driver's
license so so a third party ends up
registering the cars for some
undocumented person so that LS itself
for a total mess the police officers
never know who they're dealing with they
don't know who owns the cars they that
there's a a big web of stuff that could
just be resolved if we just allow the
people to to uh be who they are and and
and to have some type of identification
and H and know the rules of the road and
make sure that everybody can be held
accountable if they fail so for all of
this uh I just urge you to please uh
vote in favor of this
Bill thank you very much thank
you for the statement made about the
police before uh we're not going to be
offering any questions chair
recognizes Bill plug in support of the
bill hi um my name is uh is actually
Bill plug um but it's a tough name it's
a tough name to pronounce uh thank you
so much for giving me this
opportunity coming towards the end here
I I I'm not going to repeat anything
that anyone has said what I I'd like to
do is amplify the situation that an
asylum Seeker experience is here in New
Hampshire I I work with several Asylum
support groups in the state including
one here in the Upper Valley uper upper
Connecticut Valley and um the situation
is much as what uh representative
welkowitz uh discussed they come here
they need need to um they come here with
legal a certain kind of legal status
often um their first task is to file an
asylum claim and then once they uh file
an asylum claim they are eligible to
apply for work
authorization once they get work
authorization there they get uh the
ability to apply for soci security
number and then only then with the
social security number are they eligible
to apply for a
license so right now the period of time
that that can take between arrival here
in New Hampshire and the legal
opportunity to apply for a license is at
a minimum a year so they're here without
that ability ability to drive for at
least a year uh and for all the reasons
given that's a very difficult situation
to be in in New Hampshire and um a a a
product of this bill would be that
they'd be able to apply earlier for a
driver's license so I'll end right with
that point and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you Mr blo
I do see a couple of questions
representative uh thank you Mr chairman
my my um it's not really a question it's
just uh something for you I think you
might have misunderstood what the
previous witness was saying about the
police she was trying to say that police
in their home countries are often
corrupt so they tend to fear police in
general I don't think she was making a
statement about American police or our
uh criminal justice system or anything
like that
so that's not how it was heard but even
so so I did not stop her from speaking
right let her finish that that's what I
understood when she talked about that so
misunderstanding but that's not how I
took it representa pleer yes thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr
PL uh in in your
experience typically someone goes to the
position they have to show ID and and
insurance and so on uh and normally that
would be a driver's license in your
experience how do those that do not have
a license show ID when they
go for medical appointment in in
particular um so so they do have some uh
a
permission from um you know they've been
released into this country uh they've
passed a credible fear interview and
they've been released to a uh uh to to
to travel to the inside the United
States so they have that um in that that
sort of uh legal permission and other
than that I I I can't I can't answer
what they use to identify themselves um
they may have um identification from
their home country but other than that
um I'm not sure what they use to
identify
themselves okay thank
you see for the
questions sorry about that they're in
the room my representative mataro thank
you Mr chairman and uh thank you Mr
pluge for testifying this morning um I'm
just
curious um how does an undocumented
person apply for Asylum and by that what
I mean
is where who processes the application
um which agency or or What entity does
that uh actually I I'm I'm not really
fully competent to answer that question
uh so sorry to maybe another speaker can
can jump in but I I I don't I'm not
totally familiar with the details of
that perfect thank you very much you
have an also represent speak yeah thank
you Mr chairman my my question is thank
you Mr for your testimony taking my
question it's kind of a followup to U
the other representative's question in
regards to process maybe you may not be
able to answer this but once they start
going through this Asylum claim process
do they get some documentation or some
paperwork as they're going through this
process oh yeah Absol absolutely they I
mean they have uh documentation of
having uh legal Presence at some point
yes okay thank
you so no further questions thank you
very
much thank
you okay getting
close um chair
recognizes Viola
C Granite State organizing
project
hello hello can hear you
now great uh good morning members of the
House Transportation committee thank you
for the opportunity to speak for the
record my name is Viola Kim and I worked
for the grind State organizing project
which is a grassroot organization that
brings Faith labor and Community groups
to work towards more a more just world
I'm here to express our support for HB
uh 3 3 to8 um most of our work at the
Grand State organizing project involves
working with immigrants we encounter uh
undocumented immigrants every day in the
work that we do and this bill would
benefit so many individuals an example
is someone that I know personally who
has been in this country for over 20
years she works as a home care Aid
taking care of the elderly she pays
taxes using her individual tax
identification number but one of the
obstacles uh to her work is that what
what she does and where she goes is is
dependent on the transportation she has
to rely on friends for rights sometimes
she has to walk if the bus isn't
available she's a contributing member of
this state so why can't we allow
individuals like her to obtain a
driver's license stories like this are
very common we've had so many today but
i' would also like to speak on a
personal experience when I was waiting
for the renewal of my Visa
um I was worried about what I would do
if I did not get that paper in time uh
cuz my driver's license uh is tied to um
my Visa and um I was very fearful
because I was still legal here still
working here but not having that
driver's license meant that I either I
have to make choices either to drive
without a driver's license or figure out
some other sort of way which is really
difficult in Hampshire but lucky for me
my Visa was approved in time that I was
able to renew my driver's license which
is attached to my which is um the
process itself and the dates are tied
together uh but if I had to make a
choice of driving by a driver's license
and I was ever stopped I could get a
record and for for the record for
everyone here I don't have anything on
my record currently and that fear is um
for me I was lucky enough to get the
papers on time but that's not the case
for many families and the other
opposition we've had about this
legislation is voting um I've been in
Hampshire for almost 10 years now I've
had a driver's license but I do know
that that driver's license does not
award me the opportunity or the
eligibility to vote and for those
reasons I know I'm not a citizen I'm not
an eligible voter and I do not
participate in voting because I know
that that would jeopardize my status
here and that's the case with Miss
immigrants we will not go through that
process where we know that if we did
something like that it's criminal and
it's going to jeopardize our status so I
just wanted to relay that information
for anyone that has concerns about
people having driver's license and
voting I have never voted and I will
never vote I know that that's illegal I
know I'm not eligible and so many
immigrants know that so I want to urge
committee members today to vote out to
pass on HB 3 to8 thank you for your
time time would you uh are you taking
any
questions
yeski thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I
wanted to ask this to someone previously
we've heard testimony that undocumented
persons are um still driving because
they need to get to work or school or
doctor's appointments does that mean
that they are not getting car insurance
do you know if you can get car insurance
on a vehicle if you are not a licensed
driver uh I'm aware of that situation uh
but my guess is that someone could go
through a third party if um if they
wanted uh if they wanted Insurance on
their car but again I believe there
might be some people on this call that
are listening to this sharing that have
better answers uh that have dealt with
this case thank
you questions thank you very
much here recognizes Fergus gullen it's
Board of the
bill didn't see her name on the
list Mr chairman can you hear
me okay thank you very much uh my name
is Fergus Cullen I grew up in Guilford
New Hampshire I am a resident of Dover
where I am a member of the city council
in addition to that as it happens I am a
former chairman of the New Hampshire
Republican party I'm speaking asking you
to vote ought to pass on HB 328 now for
some this may be an abstract issue um
but I want to tell you about a time when
I was involved in an incident uh
involving an undocumented person who was
stopped driving a vehicle that I owned
uh this happened about 10 years ago uh
the per I got a call one night from a
police officer in a town in
Massachusetts it was after around 10:00
at night uh they had stopped a uh a
vehicle that I owned uh for a moving
violation and so the driver of the car
did not have a license now so what does
the officer do they have a guy who
doesn't have a license who's driving a
car that doesn't belong to him so they
call up that the car was registered and
wolfroad New Hampshire uh where I owned
a small business at the time and so they
called they track me down that way it
ended up I had to drive down to that
town in Massachusetts uh to you know
explain the situation to the identified
as the owner of the vehicle they
released the vehicle to me H they
released the driver with a Summons the
driver was a friend of one of my
employees who was uh free to use that
car and had lent it to a buddy of of his
um so I also want to acknowledge you
know and so that's how the situation
happened um and you know in the end to
me it was not AIG big deal but uh but
you know it happened in the real world
now this bill is obviously related to
immigration and I want to mention that
uh my parents immigrated to this country
as adults uh they ended up settling in
lonia New Hampshire where and I was
raised in in Guilford along with three
of my brothers uh my dad had uh had come
to the US for his medical residency in
Boston had ended up getting drafted uh
although he was an Irish citizen he was
drafted into the US Army during Vietnam
served a year in Vietnam as an army
surgeon even though he was not a citizen
of this country after his honorable
discharge he ended up settling in New
Hampshire my mom who has also became a
naturalized citizen went on to serve on
the school board in Guilford for many
years and I feel responsibility to help
other immigrants uh in a way in to repay
the parent my parents for the
opportunities uh that they gave me and
my brothers now today my father is
retired he is in his 80s he lives in a
nursing home in lonia and when I visit
him I can't help but notice that many of
those providing care to him are
immigrants of a younger generation and
uh it's a reminder that they are here to
work they are here to better themselves
I again I'm the city councel in Dober
and uh we have undocumented people
living and working in our community I
think that uh this bill recognizes the
reality that this population exists in
New Hampshire and that enhances Public
Safety
uh to give them a driver's license uh
with that I'll yield my time and yes I'm
open to questions if any members of the
committee have them thank you very
much I see no questions so thank you
again thank
you yeah J recognizes director
Blacky thank you
director
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh am I coming in loud enough
right great great thank you um for the
record my name is Elizabeth Bei director
of Motor Vehicles and today I'd like to
speak to you in opposition to this bill
um I will be very brief um and leave
some time for questions I know you're
over your time already there um some
Provisions that we have um real concerns
about in this bill including a provision
that speaks to the fact that we would be
required to notify an individual if
there was an inquiry um made about them
from um an agency that enforces
immigration laws um we are concerned
that that could potentially constitute
interference with an criminal
investigation or just interference with
an investigation so that that is a point
that I wanted to make um there are some
questions that we have or issues that we
have with the list of reliable official
documentations but we could easily work
with the sponsor on that as well but
perhaps the biggest issue that we have
is that this bill does not provide clear
Authority for the division to issue
licenses for those without a legal
status for example currently under RSA
263 39a there specific Provisions that
allow us to issue licenses to those
non-resident aliens that are here on a
temporary status and that points out to
those attending private educational
institutions or public institutions and
those that are engaging in lawful law uh
employment I think what this bill is
missing is really clear authorization
for us to issue licenses to those
without legal status and I'm not seeing
that um as part of this bill as well
with that I will and my testimony and
I'm happy to actually I will take that
back for a second I I do want to just
bring up another point there was a lot
of discussion about the Asylum status as
well and I I do want to remind the
committee that last year I believe
representative Sykes had introduced the
bill it was HB um
1700 that attempted to introduce to this
particular law RSA 269 39a another
category of individuals that would be
allowed to obtain a license and that was
those who have found filed a complete
application for an asylum status so um
but I believe that bill may have been a
victim of the pandemic as well so if if
you'd like to take a look at that bill
as well I think the language was there
and I know we worked with a sponsor on
that language as well with that I will
end my testimony and I'm happy to answer
any questions that you might
have see one represent
lki thank you Mr chairman thank you
director for taking my question I guess
I'm a little confused about um not your
last point about the Asylum bill I do
remember that um very well but about the
um it doesn't provide the authority to
issue licenses um can you maybe break
that down a little bit
because um I guess as I'm looking at
this it looks like they're adding this
line in as um another option are you
saying that potentially this needs to go
elsewhere um what I'm seeing is that
that the bill introduces a number of
documents that could be presented to us
for identification
purposes but I am not seeing a part of
the bill that authorizes the department
to issue a license to someone who does
not have a lawful
status So currently when we issue a
license we verify either US citizenship
or for those that are not citizens we
are requiring proof of legal um presence
in the US particularly under RSA 26339 a
this bill seems to be lacking that that
um specific
authorization to issue licenses to those
without legal
status follow
up thank you so I'm looking at page
three starting at um line four where
it's says the issuances of licenses
application oh I'm sorry yeah number
four under there where it shows the
documents that can be used um so what
you're saying is this is not enough even
though it's specifies that someone um
could present these other forms of
documentation
exactly would
sorry may I clarify one more
thing
yes um
so where would you require that
authorization I mean it doesn't go here
is what I'm I'm trying to figure out um
right um I would suggest adding another
paragraph either within
26938 maybe calling it 38b just to
provide a clear authorization that
because again the law clearly dis um
clearly identifies the narrow scope of
those non-resident aliens um that are
that are currently qualified for a
license so potentially maybe looking at
a b or another paragraph within that
section thank you thank you
questions than thank
you chair recognizes
Sebastian
[Music]
un muted now can you hear
us thank you chairman can you guys hear
me we can
now we can hear you now thank you
chairman and members of the commune
thank you very
much can you guys hear me yes we
can go
ahead thank you chairman and uh to the
members of the committee thank you very
much I would like to start this uh just
I'm G to be really brief but you to get
give us your name for the record please
Bastian Fuentes and I'm calling from
thoron New Hampshire thank you I just
want to um also just kind of separate
this conversation a little bit we I I
hear a lot about talking about
undocumented
immigrants uh you know non US citizens
but one thing that we also need to
remember is uh granting driver license
to undocumented individ also benefit uh
our homeless citizens also people
reentering soci Society uh from being
incarcerated for example um you
know uh for let say this way you know
undoc immigrants are not the only
residents they're going to
benefit individuals that are affect of a
homelessness or returning from
incarceration for example some of them
don't have a passport or some of them
don't even have a birth certificate or a
social security card available so
Gathering all these documents sometimes
it takes a lot time and and some you
know it can be
expensive um provid and driver license
es n IDs to individuals can help them
you know if you're a homeless person
search for a home or get a job you know
I
work just lost
them
what
happened you do you know what might have
happened representable
har it looks like he um just muted he
just needs to unmute looks like he just
unmuted well sorry I don't know what's
happening to the to the zo call but I
don't know when it's the last the last
part you guys hear
me shortly after you were talking about
the the difficulty the homeless people
without passports
has yeah absolutely I just want to make
sure that you know we we separate that
conversation is not only
immigrants uh being hurt by this but
also uh homeless people and people
re-entering Society from from being in
jail for example but uh going back to
the topic I just want to share with you
that for three years of my life here in
the United States especially in New
Hampshire I was an undocumented
immigrant and I wish back then I had a
license to be able to drive my daughter
to school or my son to a medical
appointment or even just driving to
soccer class soccer camp so uh I think
this bill will benefit many people will
make the road safer for many Gran
Staters so I'm asking you here please to
support this bill and uh thank you very
much sir see no questions thank you
again okay recognizing recognizes H Al
still Havey representable
ER need to unmute okay there you go
hello can you hear me can now good good
awesome thank you so much my name is
Asma El honei and I am with rights and
democracy New Hampshire we're a
Grassroots organization that promotes
human rights um I just first want to
start off by addressing what the DMV uh
person said in regards to 263 statuette
that doesn't allow issuing driver's
licenses um this actually does allow the
DMV to issue driver's licenses because
it amends the section to issue licenses
without a social security um the list of
the documentation that is being amended
is compliant with the list from the
reciprocity schedule under the
Department of State uh which is the same
list that the DMV uses uh the statue the
statute does not prevent law enforcement
from getting records from DMV for
criminal investigation um only civil
investigations so that's the main
difference so the Clause is merely to
prevent ice from um fishing for
information of undocumented immigrants
in DMV's database like um exactly what
happened in Vermont uh so um yeah so I
just wanted to share that uh and also um
just wanted to share that the majority
of people in the United States that are
here without documentation actually came
uh legally and then uh most people just
couldn't um like renew because of
language barriers Etc uh and so the fact
is undocumented people are here there
are 15,000 you saw estimates between 15
to 17,000 undocumented people in our
state they are driving whether we like
it or not so why not create Avenues to
make it safer for all of us so that
they're going through um Avenues where
they're getting tested and so um also I
just wanted to sh say that if I was for
example undocumented and I hit a car um
I would not stay because of the fact
that the possibility of it could be
detrimental to me because I don't have a
license and I'm afraid I'm going to be
deported so of course I'd flee the scene
versus if I had a license I would feel
comfortable enough to stay so that when
police came I have something to offer
them um so it's just all around safe for
everyone and I highly recommend that we
uh pass this bill
please you very much see no questions
from the committee thank you again good
afternoon Mr chair I just want to bring
a
point Travis's head headset has died and
he's charging it for uh the exec session
later so he can't really hear what's
going on in the hearing last
speaker I can hear just trying to keep
it on the charger so it charges before
the meeting okay
okay uh chair
recognize Eileen
she
hi
can you hear me okay um and I would like
to read a testimony from a fellow
Dartmouth
student to whom it may concern my name
is Juan Quinones sepa and I publicly
voice my support for HB 328 I'm a
current Dartmouth student and a
co-director of the Coalition for
immigration reform and equality at
Dartmouth as well as a co-founder for
the forza Farm Workers Fund in my role
and through the years I have seen the
challenges that undocumented people face
at Dartmouth the Upper Valley and New
Hampshire as a United States citizen I
have the privilege of navigating this
space differently than my undocumented
neor neighbors I don't worry about
issues of legality or concerns of using
motorized vehicles to navigate spaces
outside of Dartmouth yet because of the
current political reinforcement of the
driving license requirements in New
Hampshire you are political
Representatives that if I may remind we
helped elect are causing direct harm to
residents of New Hampshire contrary to
what the proponents against this bill
try to instill upon you allowing folks
to gain access to a driver's license
will in fact raise New Hampshire's
economy contribute to Community
inclusion and increase the cultural and
social growth of the state we all can
remember the fear of isolation and
unpredictability we felt and still do
since the pandemic while some of us are
only privileged to have recently
experienced these feelings for this past
year but many of our neighbors have been
living with these fears since they first
moved to New Hampshire there's no
denying that we have had rough and
dividing Year let us now turn to light
and away from Darkness to Hope instead
of fear and to include i usion instead
of hate I urge you all to vote Yes on HB
328 um and this is once again from Juan
quinot sepa co-director of co-fired En
fora farm work workers fund um thank you
very
much questions from the committee thank
you
again that's the end of the ones that I
have I'm going to circle back though I
may have
noticed Melissa bis Lopez just saw her
on the list don't believe she has
opportunity to speak
yet yeah he everyone can you all hear me
can good afternoon great um my name is
Melissa I am a Dartmouth student um but
I will read be reading a testimony on
behalf of another dartman student who
felt very strongly about this issue um
so here the testimony goes as follow um
dear representative Walsh and members of
the House Transportation committee my
name is Megan karthy and I submit this
written test in strong support of HB 328
I am currently a Dartmouth student and
the co-director of communications for
dart's Coalition for immigration reform
and equality as a member of the broader
New Hampshire and Upper Valley
communities I respect and value my
undocumented peers and neighbors the
passage of HB 328 would not only benefit
undocumented persons and provide them
with the dignity they deserve but it
would also promote Road Safety stimulate
the economy and Foster a greater sense
of community and inclusivity allowing
undocumented individuals to to receive
driver licenses would respect their
dignity as fellow members of our shared
Community all people have a right to
food housing and medical care and
drivers's licenses would make these
resources more readily accessible
additionally driver's licenses would
ensure Road Safety because it guarantees
that everyone who drives on the road has
been properly assessed and qualified by
the state furthermore having driver's
licenses can make undocumented persons
more active members of the economy it
would be easier to travel to work and
engage with local businesses as
consumers finally undocumented
individuals would be able to participate
more frequently in cultural and
community events because driver's
licenses would make these activities
more accessible and inclusive for the
aforementioned reasons I strongly urge
you to uphold Our Community Values by
voting in favor of HB 328 thank you very
much yep would you take a
question oh yes my bad I will pH thank
you Mr chairman um do I understand that
those are not your words you are
expressing them for someone else right I
am um uh speaking this uh on behalf of
this written testimony that was written
by a Dartmouth student um that goes by
the name of meanna karthy for the
record thank you
you seeing no others thank you
again um circling back the last one I
have was uh Mariana Marcelino and I
still do not see your
list do not
think do not see it no more hands raised
I'm going to close the public hearing on
house bille 328 for those that asked
earlier the people that did sign in on
the bill electronically uh 292 support
seven opposed two
neutral so that sorry can you Mr
chairman I'm sorry can you repeat that
you went really fast sorry 292 support
seven oppos two neutral thank you very
much who have signed up
electronically uh so that ends and I
will close uh the public hearing of
House Bill
328 okay hang tight for a second for
future
plans
all right I did schedule the executive
session for 11:30 so I've got to be
official open up the executive session
um on House
Bill hold on Don't
Panic
100 um now I'm going to recess the
public hearing on House Bill 100 until
1:30 that gives us time for some lunch
and to talk about some of the bills that
we uh we heard this
morning rad if you could put something
up that reflects our recess that'd be
great thank
you
that's
Brad if you're on am I assuming that our
colleagues are maybe having a quick
caucus before we get
going I'm not sure if they are or not
but I don't see them in the room right
now so they might be all right just
thought I'd double check make sure we
weren't missing something thank you not
a problem
e
got to get
my2 we
on
yes
for
that's a
[Music]
question can't imagine we go back to nor
my work on a
halfer
for
this
well
more
for
okay sound check we
here okay thank you sorry for the
delay
all right I'm going to reopen the
executive session on House Bill 100
relative to driving to the left of an
unbroken painted
line chair recognizes representative
gagy for a
motion chairman
ipit 100 have a
second
secondes
Crawford you care to speak to your
motion yes sir U very simply I've read
both of these
rsas and I can see why they might Adit
some confusion so what it does is it
mels these
two similar rsas 265 22
comma and RSA 65
37-1 d a
a 1 by by adding to 26522
1D section e
which makes
it which Ms it with RSA
26537 no law enforcement stops people
for
Crossing
unpainted blind in the highway to
avoid or bicycles or anybody on the road
work on the
road that both of these will say the
same thing you can do
saf thank you any other from the
committee seeing
none the motion on the floor is to pass
on house 100 I'll ask the cler to call
the RO as soon as she's
ready um Vice chair
daging yes clerk votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Hill yes representative Aaron yes
representative
Ankerberg yes representative borski yes
representative O'Hara yes representative
patero yes representative
Sykes yes representative cleever yes
representative Fenton yes representative
Pickering yes representative Rich yes
representative
tersi yes representative
Fox yes representative
Stevens yes representative a yes
chairman Walsh
yes 19
consent consent been moved any
objection seeing none consent
is what was the final vote Mr chairman 1
Z 20 I'm sorry 19 19 Z 190 thank you
2019 of US unless we got an extra one
let me know yeah no you're right
I I think you
voted I I'd be I'd be happy to take that
extra vote if you're willing to give it
all
right that closes it on 100 few minutes
for a reset a couple of
[Music]
minutes
okay open up the executive session on El
Bill
421 relative to organ donation on a
driver's license chair recognizes
representative O'Hare for a motion um I
moved to op the pass
421 wish to speak your motion yeah just
briefly real quick um so your license is
like a sworn document like your will so
if the individual chooses to donate
their organs that should not be changed
because that is their final wish and if
they wanted to change it they could do
so in their lifetime as hold by
department vehicle to
us anybody else
other
comments okay um motion on the floor is
not to pass on House Bill
421 um chair cl to call the RO whenever
she's ready thank you
uh Vice chair gagy yes clerk votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
Hill yes representative Aaron yes
representative
Ankerberg yep represenative borski yes
representative oara yes representative
poo yes representative sites yes
representative clever yes representative
Fenton yes representative Pickering yes
representative Rich yes representative
torski yes representative Fox yes
representative
Stevens yes representative AO yes
Walsh yes 19
Zer 19 Z
consent consent call any
objections seeing none consent that
is reject all
for
okay we open up the executive session on
House Bill 17 five relative to
reciprocal driver
education chair recognizes represented
Prof a motion um thank you Mr chair uh
i' I I
um just like a blank it's been a long
day itl on
175 went the full cramon
there am I talking seconded by
representative
gagy do you want to try to
speak I think um this bill would require
the commissioner of Department of Safety
to issue a driver's license to any
individual who provide satisfactory
evidence of completion of a course of
driver ed in any state and the bill is
really unnecessary motor vehicle already
handles these reciprocity driver
education requests and um basically they
have documentation on their website
telling people what they need to do and
we were told that the Department of
Motor Vehicle handles about 20 ofs a
year so it really is
unnecessary further
discussion seeing none Bo it'll be nice
if they all go like this the motion on I
hope I just didn't Jinx motion on the
floor is H
175 um
itl that's to call the r she's right
Vice chair gaging
yes clerk votes yes representative Smith
yes representative Hill yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative borski yes
representative Hara yes representative
poo yes representative syes yes
representative cever yes representative
Fenton yes representative Hickory
yes representative Rich yes
representative
torki yes representative Fox yes
Stevens yes representative Au yes wal
yes 19 to
zero consent been moved
objection seeing
none closes uh executive session of
175 couple minutes
please
now actually just looking at
that there's amendments possible there I
have an amendment on 496 that I don't
believe everybody has
yet um so why don't we just keep going
through the ones with no amendments we
can take a little intermission and a few
share those amendments and
then so why don't
we why don't we go into house bill
6288 you
ready I know what you're do
that's okay just I
don't okay okay open the executive
session up on House Bill
628 that is relative to maximum vehicle
speed
limitations chair recognizes
representative Hill for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I would move retain on
House Bill 628 motion is retained is
there a second second by represent
Gagney do you care to wish to speak to
the motion I will briefly um I will just
to say that um I think the original Bill
had Merit I I don't agree with certainly
a blanket across the board increase um
but I think there are places within New
Hampshire that the roads were designed
sufficiently well that uh uh some roads
could see an increase in mileage just
the way U 93 has seen from um exit 17
North so I would think that uh it may be
something that the committee would like
to explore for other roads within New
Hampshire any other
discussion
g g h go ahead represent
SE thank you Mr chairman um if I
understand the intention then in
retaining this bill is that there would
be further work done by the committee uh
before we bring it back for an executive
session well it's if we retain it be
before the committee by is it the
deadline November no
I haven't decided how I'm going to do
all these subcommittees yet a lot of
these we I'm going to obviously reach
out to the sponsor see how much they
want to
participate so I guess I'm missing
misunderstanding it
chis well okay so let me try that again
um my I I just wanted to I one of the
we've all heard in the past that bills
that get retained are often considered
to be just a way of polite
death and I I want to be I was trying to
get an understanding from the chairman
whether we'll actually work on this bill
or
whether eventually it'll just come back
in the fall and we'll we'll vote on it
again without without having had an
opportunity to work on it Noe absolutely
not I'm glad you rephrase the question
for clarification um I'm not that kind
of guy I don't do retention is a is a
polite way to kill something the only
exceptions we were asked to do possibly
this time were to uh look at limiting
you know the floor time with our our
session but but that's not me I don't do
it like that if we retain them it's for
a good reason um and I do expect we'll
work on it if it helps you I spoke with
the prime sponsor of this I explained to
him the problems with the bill he gave
us the first time he gets it he's fine
with us retaining it and is willing to
help us work on
it thank you
thank you um I guess I'm a little
confused by this motion um
since I look at this and as the previous
speaker who made the motion stated it's
you know a blanket um raise the speed
limit but it sounds like you want to
retain it to work on addressing specific
roadways and I was under the impression
that the do
already um has a process for addressing
speed limits on different roadways so I
guess I'm I'm just a little confused as
to what the intent would be when we
don't have specific roads or or projects
in mind that were pointed out to us or
not projects is the wrong word specific
roadways well do has always had a
process for raising speed limits but yet
us we as a legislature also have the
opportunity to make changes on top of
that like we did with 93 seven years AG
approximately seven years ago uh so
that's the only thing that was looking
at with this bill by retaining it is to
possibly look at a couple other specific
local that we might be able to do the
same thing we did with 93 if at the end
of the day the committee can't find any
or the subcommittee rather can't find
any that legitimate or worth it well
then we'll look at it the
fall in my opinion there are a few
around the state that
webly may
I don't think it's going to be on the
small state two lane roads but some of
States okay thank you just I'm having
trouble your your audio is going in and
out um but I think I I think I got the
gist of what you're saying is is you
think there are some roadways that we
can address and we'll give it that time
Y and if we're successful at it Ling it
in the
fall any other discussion and am I
coming in any better
yes a little bit a little bit yeah I
think it was you were turning away and
and looking at your notes while you were
speaking
perhaps all right any other no other
discussion motion on the floor is to
retain House Bill
628 ask call the r whatever she's
ready Vice chairman gagie yes thir FES
yes representa Smith yes representative
H yes representative Aaron yes yes
representative anber yes Gorski yes
representative
O'Hara yes representative Tero yes
representative sites no Representative
cever
no no thank you representative Fenton no
representative Pickering no
representative Rich no
tersi
no
Fox no representative
Stevens no representative Ao no
representa h excuse me chairman Walsh
yes
109 I closes the motion to retain as
adopted um that closes the ex session at
68 just a few
moments
sure
up the executive session on House Bill
386 relative to the operation of certain
on watcha
Pond hey all right I
do chair represent uh chair recognizes
representative pataro for a motion thank
you Mr I move to Vote IPL on
house is there a second
second by
Hill would you care to speak to your
motion I just find the failure to need
to see the immediacy of passing
legislation like
this anybody else wish to speak
representative
SES thank you Mr chairman um as I had
indicated in my uh introduction of the
bill that this uh establishes a a
precedent for fish and game and for the
Department of Safety Marine Patrol to
make
uh to acknowledge the need for making uh
law that would reflect the needs of
persons who are handicapped that was the
specific reason why this bill was
brought forward I
um while I acknowledge that it won't
affect a ton of people um I think it's
still an important policy decision that
the this committee the transportation
committee be
encouraging uh the adoption of laws that
would uh answer people who are
handicapped being able to use the
recreational resources of the state
which they pay equally in order to do
and um
and for that reason I would urge a no
vote on this on this
motion else wish
to seeing none I'll uh I'll
reply uh on this I do remember the
hearing I believe it was Marine Patrol
that was also opposed to this bill uh
for exactly that setting
precedence and I have to be honest
representative I believe it was your own
words no I don't believe it were your
words that the basic intent of this was
to limit as many people from going there
as possible which is really not
something I can support
so that's all I have I uh I will be
voting to support the
itl a
discussion seeing none motion on the
floor is an itl on House Bill
386 well they are
the to call the rooll whenever she's
ready I'm in the
clerk is ter Dy yeah clerk folks yes
representative Smith yes representative
Hill yes representative Aaron yes
representative anber yes representative
bski yes
representa yes
representa yes Representative syes no
representative FL no represent Fenton no
no representative Pickering no
representative Rich no representative
tki sorry no thank you representative
Fox no representative Stevens no sen ve
no Jaron Walsh
yes votes uh 10 itl closes the exec
session on
386 uh are you going to be doing a
Minority Report
anybody um I will I'll write a Minority
Report but I would not expect there to
be a debate necessarily fair enough
thank
you couple of minutes to
regroup
yeah down list 515
next
okay I'm G open up the executive session
on house 5:15 relative to
confidentiality for reporting possibly
medically unfit drivers J recog unit as
representative Hill for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I'd
like to move itl on House Bill
515 is there a
second gag you wish to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chairman um I think
uh most of us are sensitive to the
concerns heard in testimony from the
prime sponsor indicating how difficult
it is sometimes to begin the process of
removing driving privileges from friends
neighbors or family
members uh this bill tends to tries to
make that easier by allowing the
reporting process to take place behind
the V veil of
secrecy um however the uh testimony from
the director of the DMV giving
statistics that it really is only about
20 occurrences in
2020 um and also the fact that she
personally oversees all cases and feels
strongly that new is beyond reproach in
terms of handling cases with compassion
and professionalism um I think we're
working well and I think we should leave
the situation as it
stands else wish to speak
discuss seeing none motion on the floor
is itl on House Bill
515 must cler call R whenever she's
right chairman gagy yes clerk votes
yes Smith yes representative Hill yes
representative Aaron yes representative
anber yeses borski yes representative
oara yes representative P yes
representative sites yeses CL yes
representative Fenton yeses picking yes
representative Rich yes representative
chorki yes
Fox yes pres
Stevens yes
V yes chairman Walsh yes 19 to
zero consent been moved any
objections seeing none consent that
is Clos on
5:15 few minutes to regroup we'll be
doing 5 22
that Mr chair you do have my BL right I
did
okay open up the U executive session on
House Bill 522 FN relative to motor
vehicle inspections for new vehicles
chair
represent representa warski for a motion
thank you Mr chairman um I would like to
make a motion to retain um House Bill 52
here a
second a bit of guy care to care to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chairman I think uh this particular Bill
although has some merits there's still
some things that need to be worked on
the definition of new for example there
different perspectives on that so I
think there's some issues here that have
to be worked out for us before we can
consider
any enough any further
discussion
for your hand you are representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman um yeah have
some anxieties about this bill I just
think it is fundamentally flawed I'm not
positive that we can fix it it's got
enough issues that I would have to vote
against a a retaining motion um in the
chance that we might get an OT uh itl
out of it but I think it's just too
fundamentally flawed and uh we're going
to
have I don't know how many retained
bills we are going to have but there's
going to be a lot of them and I wonder
wonder and worry that we will have time
to do it justice in that
regard I
also there's no other
discussion I did speak with the uh Prim
sponsor is this as well he's fine with
to rain and is eager to learn and does
recognize that his initial language had
some problems um I think the theory is
there I don't think the problems are
that hard to get worked out um really
don't see a heavy load so I ask the
committee to support
the any
else none motion on the floor is retain
on House Bill 522 FN cl to call the RO
whenever she's
ready Vice chair gagy yes clerk votes
yes representative Smith
yes yes Aaron yes representative anber
yes corsky yes representative Hara yes
representative bero yes Representative
syes no representative clever no
representative Fenton no representative
Pickering no representative Ridge no
representative tersi noesa Fox
no have
Stevens
noo no
wal
yes 109 routine closes session at
522 next
up next up see here
go into one this morning House Bill 352
next give us a couple of
minutes Mr
chairman
um I I just want to make make note of my
um objection to executing bills that we
just heard the public hearing in of
earlier today I I do this with being
mindful of the fact that
um much of our testimony today offered
issues and opportunities to impr improve
the bill uh through an amendment process
that will not be possible if we exec the
bill today um I I believe strongly that
a there is no reason for any um Rush on
Executive today as as I seem to call
reading in the calendar that the that
the speaker has extended the deadlines
um there's also the possibility that we
could you know make these bills a little
better by uh doing a different motion
and having the Senate um fix them if we
have to vote on them today but I I think
it would be a much better legislative
process reflecting the needs of the
public to give the opportunity to this
committee to make changes on the bills
that they might see that they may see
um as as necessary and possible so I
just want that objection noted and then
we'll have further debate about whatever
motion might be fair enough objection
noted um I will go on to say that yes we
can do it in our
rules I also made it fully aware first
first of all I have not taken advantage
of the system
but I did make mention that this was my
intention a week ago and fully knowing
we could have the opportunity to discuss
them before the
hearing U not that we've had the hearing
I didn't hear anything at the hearing
that would change anybody's mind in
terms of myself personally I have not
heard any objections yet in terms of any
suggested amendments Etc um time is
always of the essence I really don't
want to drag this committee back up
taxpayers expense for three bills to
exec
uh we move forward with it but
noted any other
discussion this
is just making a I haven't opened it up
for 352 just making statement or did I
open it
up no I mentioned I was going to do it
next I haven't made it
official just a general statement this
point on whether or not we should be
taking up this
morning Mr chairman can I just comment
on something since you did ask if anyone
had any
comments thank you very much I
appreciate it I I I guess I disagree
with you a little bit on the fact that
we didn't hear anything this morning
that could um that came up that we
didn't wouldn't didn't know in advance
excuse me um I think there are a couple
of issues with these bills that we could
tweak verbage if someone had a concern
with them and um just to uh Echo um
representative syes the fact that the
speaker has moved out those dates we do
have a couple of weeks that we could
meet one more time to try to um fix any
problems that uh people had with these
bills and I would prefer to do that as
opposed to um shutting something now
down and and being delayed yet another
year or two years to be able to
reintroduce the bill and try again thank
you
right
now I'm just looking at my notes
here again after hearing everything this
morning I see nothing to deter us from
moving forward with this uh for those of
you that are new this is actually a
procedure that goes on all the time in
the set more often the not uh they'll
exec the bills right after they hear it
I've actually been a proponent of making
this a house rule for a long time um I
thought this was of an emergency issue
or if I thought it was something that we
could fix I would not do this but we're
going to move forward opening up the
executive session on House Bill
352 chair recognizes representative
borski for a motion thank you Mr
chairman um I would like to make a
motion to itl
hb3 is there a
second represent gag is a second wish to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chairman um you know the spirit of uh
352 I
appreciate um where the representative
was coming from in regards to um putting
in some type of trading session but I
sense that from you know reading this
bill and hearing the testimony I think
what we're doing is open up a p's box in
terms of other things that you know we
may eventually have to put on the pile
to do special training on so I think we
should just it up to
particular thank you any other
discussion seeing none oh sorry Mr
chairman I was fumbling with fumbling
with all these buttons to get out of
mute and get the hand raised um I I
would note that this um while I agree
that this bill has a couple of issues
specifically
um how would we deal with it in terms of
endorsement language endorsements are in
fact a a technique that is used
throughout for many different types of
licenses and also there was some
concerns about clarifying the definition
as the rsa's had a little bit of a
problem um I I would be I I think this
Bill had some Merit that we this is an
example that we could have worked on by
not executing it today but if we are
going to EXE
today
um I would I I would at this point be
opposed to the itl and the chance that
we could um either get it passed and fix
those few things in the senate or retain
it but uh at the moment I'm opposed to
the
itl fair enough and I I'll also agree
that there is some Merit to it I
understand it although it was based on
one accident one incident but I don't
believe this this bill needs a little
bit of work I think this bill needs a
ton of work as confessed by the prime
sponsor who said it's pretty much up to
the committee what direction we want to
go
in and you know what I I do agree we're
raining a good amount of them already um
I think this one is beyond what we could
even do as uh in anything in
retained I think if the pro Co I mean
the prime sponsors really dead set on
this uh some more work can be done on
his end and reintroduced at a later time
so for that be supporting the
itl well thank you for recognizing me I
was going to suggest the motion to
retain to work on it um I do think
that that's okay I can if I may still
share why I believe this is a good
candidate for retention um I think it's
something that has opened up the
question of uh what New Hampshire could
do to make sure that these vehicles are
driven safely on our roads uh the fact
that uh anyone can get into one of these
vehicles um and and drive one of these
massive things without any kind of
training or experience I think is is
quite problematic um I would have liked
to have seen a retain motion where we
could at least look at some of the
issues and uh see how we could address
them maybe not with an endorsement but
to see if there was anything else such
as a a training program or something
similar um but yes I I I'm afraid that
um going straight to the itl um I am not
favor of thank
you any further
discussion the motion on the floor is
itl and house bills
352 last to call the rooll whenever
she's
ready chair gading yes clerk votes yes
representative Smith yes representative
yes representa yes representative
anber yes representative bski yes
representative Hara yes representative
Peta yes representative sites no
representative clever no representative
Fenton no representative pickery no
representative Rich no Representative
torki no representative Fox no
representative
Stevens no representative Veo no
chairman
yes 10 to9 109 I closes the ex session
onal
352 let me know if you want to do a
Minority Report I will let you know Mr
chairman I'm gonna see if I can Farm it
out if there's going to be one though I
don't want to take on all of
them I have may I ask a question just on
procedure if there's a Minority Report
um I believe the minority's um motion
would have been to retain can we still
write a Minority Report with that as our
suggested motion or don't see why not
that that's your that's the motion
you're seeking as a minority so
yes okay I'll discuss it with um the
ranking I would just yeah I would check
with the clerk because I'm not sure that
what'll happen was if if we if we
overturn the committee's report that the
the next motion I think would have to be
OTP the house does not have a retained
motion does it
have a quasy parliamentarian here do you
hear
that would it have to be I'll check with
the clerk you can do retain because I
mean on the floor you could do refer
refer no so yeah okay yeah go go with
the retainer they'll tell us if we're
Rong all right we'll we'll check with
the clerk and then we'll we'll make some
kind of Minority Report won't we
representative
tersi that's my task
thanks thank you I appreciate you taking
that
on good
question have a question no I said it's
a good
question uh let me think here what we're
going to do next at some point we're
going to take a little intermission so
we can send out some
emails uh yeah some emails with some uh
amendments
one now we're on the topic of retain
BS I'm GNA open up the executive session
on House Bill 435 you
ready oh I'm sorry
okay all right ahead of myself that's
okay now I'm going open up the executive
session on House Bill
435 um chair
recognizes
representative Hill for a
motion um thank you chair I would uh I
would like to move retain on House Bill
435 435 correct is there a second second
by
represent Mr speak your
motion um sure briefly um I would just
like to say that I I was sensitive to
director B's comments I thought she made
some cogent
points uh of problems within this bill
that uh I think can be
um addressed and I thought I think it
behooves us to retain the bill and
address the concerns of the
DMV yeah I'd just like to get a moment a
bit of a clarification my notes show
that director blei was uh essentially
neutral she said they were neutral on
this bill and that she did have a small
concern that would go back to the court
but um I will point out that when this
bill was originally written
um it came out of committee last year 20
to nothing and went to the floor of the
house and a a Voice vote passed that and
was referred to criminal justice and
then died in the the uh the rest of the
session but I don't I believe that the
the question that she raised was more
from her not being familiar with the
answer rather than the fact that the the
courts did answer this very these very
same questions and so uh again I I will
just make note of my objection to
executing bills on the same day but in
the meantime um I am proba I guess I'm
opposed to retaining yet another bill
that has lots of Merit that we could
move forward in the process thank
you any further
discussion I'll just say this uh
closing um I do remember that we all
voted for this last year I don't
remember these issues coming up last
year and quite frankly last year was
last year now that these issues are
before us they were brought up by
probably the most trustworthy department
head I know of um I think the retain is
the perfect thing to do with this the
questions were not small they rain to
the Judiciary and judicial answers I
think it's the best thing to do with
this to keep it alive um I'd encourage
everybody on the committee to
any
discussion am n motion on the floor is
to rain house
435 um I'll ask call the RO she's
ready chairman dney yes CL votes yes
representative
Smith yes representative Hill
yeses yes representative anber yes for
yes representative oara
yes Tera yes representative
syes sorry
no dang mute button you were changing
your
mind Representative cever no
representative Fenton no representative
Pickering no representative Rich no sen
tersi no sen Fox no sen
Stevens no that no wsh
yes that's 109 to aain closes the exact
session on
435 okay at this point we've got uh
one two three
four
five bills
left two of the I know have amendments
that I don't believe everybody has it's
20 minutes to three
now I call just a short recess until 20
minutes to three wait hold on before you
recess the house clerk reports that
retain cannot be a Minority Report
because it isn't a report of the house
to vote on right did you catch
that can representative Smith can you
please say that um closer or slower to a
microphone I just didn't catch it all
yeah be because a motion to retain is a
committee motion the house never moves
for a committee to retain a bill and we
we have to adopt the report so instead
you would have to do OTP or something or
do a floor motion to reer it to
committee so the minority can't be
retained okay and you cannot have
re-refer as a motion on The Minority
Report you can do that on the house
floor if that's what you want to
do okay but your Minority Report would
have to be you know someh house Mo for
committee report OTP otpa like
that so in this case the OTP is the best
fit for what I'm trying to do yeah thank
you Mr chairman what time were you going
to um I think recess to I think three
o'clock would be fine that's enough time
I've got to dig up a couple of
amendments I think there's a few few
others to send it a whole
committee and uh we got five of the
bills after that we're we're in pretty
good shape so all right so I'm gonna
just just while I get everybody's
attention I'm gonna ask the Laura to
send out a Zoom request to our to our
caucus so that we can just chat a little
bit would you like a couple more minutes
then and then yeah can we have 10 more
minutes than that like at 310 so this
clock isn't accurate let's all agree on
a time that's on an accurate phone I got
2:39 actually 20 minutes enough make it
three o'clock after all or would you
like more than that no 310 just let's I
I we can we could afford 10 minutes 310
310 very good executive session recess
till three times thank
you we shut that off T yeah if you can
uh shut shut off our
feed
for
yeah
is who where are we missing the other
guy is is there three people on Zoom
from from our
side so Travis Aiden
and who's the
third but then there's so there's two
three four five six seven8 nine 10
there's 11
right oh it is I thought it was
[Music]
ready
yeah set represent SES can you hear
me I can hear you I think everybody's
here yeah can get everybody back on the
live
streen Mr chairman yes can you or the
clerk send me um a form for the um
Minority Report or majority report is
there a is there like a document that I
can receive I had sent out a template
well was a while ago you can't find it
we
s we sent out a generic that works both
for both minority or majority but if it
was a while ago so I'll send out a send
out a fresh one thanks I don't remember
getting it I appreciate it thanks if
you'd like represent a v i can resend
that to everybody as
well say one more time Brad if you'd
like I have that on file I can resend it
to everybody oh fantastic that' be great
thank
you so we're
good okay I'm going open up the
executive session on House Bill 251 FN
requiring children under the age of two
years to be restrained in a motor
vehicle is there a
motion
chair I make a
motion that representative Fenton yes
representative friend for a motion yes I
uh move off to pass as
amended we'll start with an ought to
pass can I get a motion for ought to
pass on House Bill
251 I make a motion repres represent
tarki did I see you raise your hand go
up represent I guess I'm sorry are you
seconding motion no no no I am second I
am seconding the motion seconding the
motion your hands up on the screen
that's
sorry
okay um the motion is ought to pass it
is open for further
Amendment you have another motion
representative
F yes can you hear
me
yeah we can we can hear you Dan I
Donovan I'm not sure why they didn't
respond can you hear me Mr
chair very faint very faint sorry I'm on
my my office phone and apparently we
don't pay enough for good phones
here recognize me for a second motion is
that what you said
sir yeah it's open for still open for
Amendment do you did you understand you
have another motion I do yes I'd like to
introduce Amendment 065 2 H for HB
251 you get to speak let you get a
second on that I'll second I'll
second represent
SES would you wish to speak to your
motion on the amendment absolutely so um
basically this amendment is kind of just
uh working with the committee um and the
stakeholders to kind of make everyone
happy so we updated manufacturer laws in
this um so that there's no issues or
complaints with uh instructions or if
you have larger than average children um
and we also updated the effective date
there were some issues that uh Rose
about uh the implementation date was a
little too soon so we moved this to
January 1 uh
2022 um and yeah that's pretty much the
Crux of
it could
somebody
this is the latest okay can you um
represent F we're still having a hard
time here to can you just repeat the
amendment number
again had two one one
time
0652 so if I can ask
if
06528 thank
you okay if I can ask you a question on
the amendment is
that absolutely sir was that the same
language you had on the first draft
Amendment you put out but also includes
pushing out the effective
date yeah so basically that this so it
was it was amended once to include the
manufacturer suggestions and then it was
amended again just to change the
effective date to January 1 uh 2022 but
keeping in those
manufacturer law I just want to make
sure because I know we had two in front
of us okay well one one's draft only Mr
chairman
yep
so would we have to approve both
amendments no the first one the first
one was a draft to be shared with
everybody right when he decided to
change the effective date he just had
well as use the same language on the
next Amendment the change for the
effective the first one's just going to
disappear into Oblivion thank you Mr
chair um any more discussion on the
amendment representative
Sykes yes uh Mr chairman thank you um I
just want to point out that one of the
during testimony uh Joseph kalal kalala
from the juvenile products manufacturing
association had a concern this amendment
answers that concern and then
furthermore it also takes care of the uh
effective date and so I would urge
members of the committee to vote in
favor of the
amendment representative Jill thank you
Mr chairman um could you tell me whether
the amendments deal with which safety
um agreements we're using in it the
original Bill had talked about safety
standards um does the amendment change
that or delineate or explain which
safety standards we're using are you
asking that of me or yes I am okay the
way I understand it the same the
standards that referred to and I don't
have it in front of them that's for my
problem is
too and actually if you can do a better
job of this than I represent Donovan you
can certainly Jump Right
In um yeah be happy to talk about this
and thank you to the question that's a
great um issue to bring up so it's the
the the issue is um that you're
referring to probably is the the last
sentence of the bill basically says in
accordance with safety standards so if
you look at the the bill what the safety
standards are referring to is um United
States Department of Transportation
section 213 so the the bill States um
that in accordance with safety standards
approved by United States Department of
Transportation in 49 CFR section 571
2113 so that's just reab brevia it just
so that there's no uh issues that that's
the safety standards were're referring
to and chairman Walsh if you think I
missed something feel free to yeah well
now the only I appreciate about the
amendment is it also simplifies it to if
you look at the original bill um that's
where we get into the weeds when we
start talking about inches and weights
and pounds and all this stuff that was
taken out uh the reference to uh 49 CFR
basically section
213 that would apply to paragraph 1 C as
well the way I interpret
it I
would I would encourage everybody to
vote for the
amendment
any further discussion on the
amendment seeing
none motion to adopt an amendment is on
the floor I'll ask the chair to call the
r whenever she's ready and excuse me I
am starting to lose my
voice G you'll be happy about that I
know you were gonna say something I I
was I was supposed to be with a stage
whisper that no one heard but
me
all set all set this is for the adoption
of the
amendment Vice chairman gagy yes votes
yes representative Smith yes
representative Hill yes representative
Aaron no Representative inber no
representative bski
yeses oara no representative um poo
yes representative syes yes
representative cber Yesa Fenton yes
representative Pickering yes
representative Rich yes representative
tersi yes representative Fox yes
representative
Stevens
muted
need to mute un mute representative
representative Stevens yes
sorry representative Veo yes J wsh
yes 16
to3 okay the amendment is adopted
163 motion now on the floor is ought to
pass as amended
further
discussion the passes amended
motion I just wanted to put my two cents
in here as a mother and um
having lots of contact with the way
parents either understand how to use
their car seats or not I think that this
bill is a long time coming that will be
a good educational opportunity that will
protect children and um I truly believe
that one harmed child is one too many in
our state and I would urge the committee
to please support uh 251 as
amended any further discussion
representative Ain yes so um thank you
Mr
chair I want to know I want to say that
I believe in safety and I also believe
in parental
rights uh and parents right to choose
what restraint system works best for
their child along with their
pediatrician advice parents I've spoken
to don't want any more State mandates
some kids get car sick rear-facing some
kids have long legs some kids need to
see their parents there's been no major
problem with kids dying or getting
injured and using incorrect restraints
in New Hampshire and the current US
Department of Transportation puts out a
chart that shows that there's an overlap
between the recommend recommendations
for rear-facing use which is one to
three years and forward-facing use which
is 18 months years and booster seat used
from four years to 12 years old I
believe our law already covers proper
Mandate of requiring child restraints
and we don't need to mandate anything
further and I think we should leave
restraint usage decisions of to parents
whose number one concern is their child
safety should work with their
pediatrician and um and and determine
what works best for them I've spoken to
many of my own constituents and this was
Time After Time what they have um have
asked me to express thank
you you any further
discussion seeing
none the motion on the floor is to pass
as Amendment on House Bill 5 251 fend
excuse me I'll ask
the chairman
G yes clerk votes yes representative
Smith no representative Hill no
representative Aaron no Representative
anber no representative borski yes
Representative oara
no representative uh PETA
no representative
Sykes
yes representative cever yes
representative
Fenton muted representative
Fenton
yes representative Pickering yes
representative Rich yes representa tki
yes representative Fox yes
representative
Stevens yes yes representative Veo yes
chairman Walsh
yes
13 136 the pass is amended is adopted
closes the exec session on house
b51 a couple of minutes for recess Le uh
going to move right into house Bill
[Music]
executive session House Bill
300 relative to driver
education is there a motion chairman I
would like to make a motion represent
Fon recognize for motion I move to itl
hb300
second
K is that you yes sorry I was trying to
unmute mute I do
second would you care to speak your
motion yeah absolutely um yeah we heard
testimony this bill will have a negative
influence on traffic safety in New
Hampshire and I know we don't like
talking about what we've done in the
past but we did vote this down and um I
believe you know if we want to produce a
safe and competent young drivers in New
Hampshire that this is not the way to do
it thank you further
discussion
see well representative
O'Hara thank you Mr chairman um this
still does not do away with driver's
education and parents will still have
the choice to send their kids to a
commercial drivers ed program to get the
insurance discount if they so choose
this still opens up Financial barricades
for our children to have the same
opportunity of outcome in life whether
taught by parents or by private program
the test to make sure we have safe
drivers on New Hampshire roadways is
still the same the DMV written test and
the highway safety uh practice test will
not allow um unsafe drivers on our
roadway representative
SES yes thank you Mr chairman um I would
just like to point out that the the uh
the numbers of organizations and folks
who spoke in support of this bill was
heavily weighted in favor from the um
for instance Dan Goodman of triaa um who
was in opposition to the bill I I should
say the people were opposed to the bill
to be clear clear about that um Dan
Goodman of Tria was opposed Trooper
DuPont from the M Hampshire Department
of Safety who runs the driver ed program
was in opposition director bki was
opposed um so I just I just would
caution everybody about
[Music]
um not you know sometimes it's really
important that we listen to the
professionals who have studied the
issues and we know that um I've not
heard or seen anything about actual data
that proves that people are having
trouble getting their driver's licenses
but I have in fact seen data that shows
that we have a relatively good driving
records in terms of training people and
uh we should
support uh the an itl motion for
this representative Aaron thank you Mr
chair
um I would vote to pass this bill simply
because as a parent who has taught their
children to drive um and they have done
very well for themselves
never gotten into any accidents they are
good drivers I think parents are totally
and Guardians uh responsible adults are
quite capable of teaching their children
to drive and again I think this is a
parental rights issue I think parents
should be given the option to be able to
uh to engage in teaching their children
to drive so that's where I
this represent the last
speakers
thank you Mr chairman um one of my
biggest issues I have with this bill is
the fact that there's um no specific way
to determine if the education was given
in the same level um as a driver's
education program um never mind there's
no way to determine that any education
was given um it just has someone signing
an affidavit I believe is what the
process is submit proof there's no
definition of what submit proof is I
have a problem with that um if this even
was going to be something I would
entertain I would need a lot more
details um in there to ensure that um
the drivers who are coming onto our
roadways were going to be trained in the
manner equal to all of the other young
drivers in our state so um I will be
supporting the itl thank you thank you
any further discussion from
the representative Crawford I'll make it
sure so um I'm with the itl and um the
bill doesn't
specify um the cost that it would uh I
believe um director uh the director of
Motor Vehicles said that there certainly
would need U more Personnel to look at
all of these waivers you're asking a a
mother a father a guardian or knows who
are responsible adult is to teach 30
hours of classroom 10 hours behind the
wheel instruction six hours of
observation there are no Provisions in
this bill to have a supervision of the
instruction being taught driver ed
presently is taught by licensed
instructors who are required college
credits 51 hour and staff development
hours every three years we basically um
are supervised by the department of
safety and this is basically we have to
get a do physical I mean there's a lot
to it I'm not saying that parents don't
do a halfway decent job in teaching
their kids before we get to them but I
will tell you for the first three
lessons maybe I'm correcting all the
mistakes that parents make so I would I
I don't see um the validity of it and I
I don't believe that we should put that
on parents I mean we got good parents
and we have not so good parents so I
will leave it at
that representative CER yes I agree with
what clerk just stated what she said be
okay with it some parents will be very
very good at it most will not and will
not document and and go to the extent
possible uh with our train driver
education programs I think we have good
programs they they're certified the
instruction is great whether it's
private schools or high school or what
whatever and I think that we ought to
itl this bill and and uh keep safety at
a
standard representative Stevens is that
your hand raised yes sir thank you Mr
chair um in regards to the parents I
heard from and I felt badly about this
part of the
reality um when the financial burden of
the cost of driver had came up and
certainly if you have more than one
child that you're trying to get on the
road that's a lot of
money but what the reality is is if what
you
lose is the insurance discount so I'm
not sure which side of the financial
fence that falls in favor of
but it's not as if teaching your child
gets you a financial
benefit so I'll be voting
itl
discussion see
none representative
Smith thank you Mr chair there's a
section missing from the
bill so responsible adults not defined
there's a lot of other things there it's
kind of a vague paragraph the new
paragraph section five and we did not
include afterwards the um Power of the
department who adopt rules so they can
actually do this normally there would be
a section that follows that says the
commissioner May adopt rules pursuant to
RSA was
541a that's not here so I can't vote for
this further
discussion seeing none not even have to
listen to me on this one barely speak
the motion uh on the floor is House Bill
itl last cl to call the RO she's ready
Vice chairman
gagy
yes cler votes yes representative
Smith no representative Hill no
representative Aaron no representative
Ankerberg no
was that is that a no what was that that
no Representative bski no representative
Hera no representative
poo I vote Yes on the motion to
I uh
yes cler yes representative Fenton yes
representative Pickering yes
representative Rich yes representative
tki yes representative
Fox representative
Fox you're yes did she say yes yes yes
thank you representative
Stevens representative Stevens
yes representative AO
yes and chairman Walsh
yes to
six could you repeat the M could you
repeat the vote please yeah just just
verifying 136 1 six thank you
136 itl on House Bill
300 Mr chairman sorry I was just keeping
track also I just wanted to clarify
because I thought representative Smith
said he was going to be voting for The
itl and then he verbally voted against
it that is
correct okay just
checking my eyebrows froze also okay
just checking my earbuds
here
um a few minutes to reset people getting
a little tired now but we're almost
there house B 496
next no you
didn't
Ved
rookies
11 years literally the first time that's
ever
happened you can't take it back it
doesn't
matter you can do it on one of the ones
that are coming up to representative
Smith yeah you can make just gives the
minority a better
argument he was keeping the reconsider
motion6
Mr
chairman yes thank you um just we forgot
to mention um some of the uh what used
to be the old blue sheets I'd appreciate
it if you'd mention them as we
continue which one which representative
well as an example on the last Bill we
we did not hear from you how many people
signed in in favor or opposed I was just
curious I was just asking you to make
sure you do that for the bills we move
forward on well I only remember doing
that at the time of the public hearing I
don't ever remember doing that at oh
really oh I'm sorry you're probably
right my gosh a mistake it seems to be
infectious representative
Smith
ouch
that's
representative
bless
you oh she's still
G
safer now bless you I see her smiling so
that's a good sign
okay good I'm gonna open up the
executive session on H 496 FN relative
to license plate
covers chair recognizes representative
gagy for a motion I would vote to
pass is there a
second representa Hill seconds bill is
open to further Amendment you have
another motion representa yes I'd like
to introduce amendment number 2021
[Music]
0631 yes you can defer the explanation
uh basically what all the uh Amendment
0631 H you probably heard it
uh actually it was from the same person
Richard head from uh government affairs
from the judicial branch looking back at
the Odyssey updates and how complicated
it is and how they do it he's the one
that reached out to me recommended uh
the same thing you heard on the
different builds this morning I forget
which one it was the problems they have
with the 60 days so uh all the amendment
does is move out the effective date to
January 1st 20122 that is by the request
so that is
it any further
discussion on the am Mr who seconded the
amendment with no further discussion on
the
amendment I'll ask to CL the call the RO
soon as
she Vice chairman gney
yes yes representative Smith yes
representative Hill yes representative
Aaron yes representative
anber yes representative borski yes
representative Hara yeses Tero yes
representative
sites IM
muted this is a yes for the amendment
yes thank you representa spenton oh no
excuse me representa cever
no did you say no no
no representative Fenton yes
representative piit yes representative
Rich yes representative
tersi yes representative Fox yes
representative
Stevens
yeso yes chairman Walsh yes
18 so 181 the amendment is adopted
motion on the floor is ought to pass as
amended any further discussion on on the
bill actually we should be familiar with
this one we've been talking about it for
a couple years
now seeing
none tki thank you I just wanted to um
to say that I was opposed to dispel last
term and um the testimony we heard from
Sergeant Kelby from the state police
helped um change my mind and um I will
be
supporting the
otpa thank you for that any further
discussion
seeing none I also actually I'll come
I'll be honest with you I just find it
downright annoying when I see people
trying to block their license plates
intentionally and that's what they're
doing with those things so I have no
issue with this bill I plan on voting up
to pass so the motion on the floor is
out to pass as amended if there's no
other discussion I will
ask soon as she's
ready I mean uh but you know what here
you go
yeah this
is 496 496
496 Vice chair gag yes the clerk votes
yes representative Smith yes
representative Phil yes representative
Aon yes representative
anber
yesi yes representative Hara yes
representative yes representative sites
yes cler no representative Venton yes
representative picking yes reprentative
Rich yeses tki yes Fox yes
representative
Stevens yes representative AO yes
chairman Walsh
yes
motion for
consent
consent sure move who move that is there
any Mr
chairman any objection represent
cler consent is fine thank you okay
thank you sir consent it is
Y close the EXA session on House Bill
496 couple minutes please and we're
almost there
take up house
next excuse me for moment just want to
get a little bit of
water
do you do
that that must be leadership for you
know when they usually
say
is that on that
sheet yeah I don't
know hey I don't even
[Music]
know
okay open up the executive session on
House Bill
587 FN relative to indicating
citizenship or legal residency on
driver's licenses and non drivers
identification cards sh recognizes
representative taro for a motion thank
you Mr
chair I move that we ought to pass House
Bill 587 and F okay is there a
second representative Hill that's the
second would you wish to speak to your
motion no thank you no thank you
okay all
right
represent motion
go ahead representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman um unless it
could be that my notes are incorrect but
I what I have in my notes is that at the
public hearing for this bill which
occurred on the 12th of February other
than the prime sponsor representative
gay no one spoke in favor of this bill
although the DMV was neutral
um I we heard a lot of concern from many
different citizens groups that spoke
about the discriminatory nature of this
uh this bill and I am I I I believe
strongly that the the general public um
as evidence by the the uh testimony
given to us are opposed to the B the
bill and I don't believe that we want
would want to go on record as being uh
in support of something that would be
discriminatory towards individuals um
the one issue that the DMV did bring up
was that they were concerned about the
limited real estate on the driver's
license and it was not clear um how or
where this this indication would would
end up on the card on the on the
driver's license and so I'm going to uh
request that the committee itl this bill
and not not be in support of the motion
thank you
any further
discussion representative
tar thank you very much Mr chairman um I
want to Echo um representative Sykes in
his statement of um support that we saw
in this bill on the day of the hearing
um we actually didn't get the numbers um
on the signin requested it from um
Brad and um we had
342 people signing in to oppose the bill
and 22 in support um and that's in
addition to the people who testified um
and as rep representative Sykes stated
only the sponsor testified um for this
bill I also wanted to bring up the fact
that we already have um a number of
people who are not
US citizens that hold New Hampshire
driver's license they are legal
residents um I requested some numbers
from director blei that I received um
right now in the state of New Hampshire
there are
2,814 driver's licenses that have been
issued to non-citizen permanent
residents and
2,867 non-driver IDs
so that's a total of
28,6 181 pieces of identification that
we're talking about here um where these
people who are here legally working
raising their families contributing uh
to our economy are now going to be um
opening themselves up to discrimination
every time they um need to hand their
license over to anyone um which we could
go into the whole list of different
situations where one presents a driver's
license but I think we've all heard them
before um I think it's unfair to put
these hardworking people um at risk like
that and make them a second class uh
resident of the State of New Hampshire
um and I would hope that um the
committee could not support the aut to
pass motion um in a hopes that another
motion may be made thank
you
Cleaver yes thank you Mr chairman this
bill is clearly
discriminatory frankly I think it would
be embarrassing for New Hampshire to
adopt such a
ruling and uh I I'm strongly opposed to
it discriminatory to the max thank
you go ahead representative sites yeah
I'm sorry there was one point I thank
you Mr chairman one point I wanted to
make too um it's not clear to me um what
the benefit would be of doing this that
isn't covered by other areas of the law
and in addition to that um there's a
fiscal note attached to this that says
at a minimum it's going to cost
$52,000 in order to make these changes
and I just I it it escapes me about why
we would want to spend the harder tax
dollars in order to make a this type of
change which has from what I can see
little or no um good good per little or
no purpose that has been
identified thank
you Z
Smith uh thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to address the real estate on the
license issue there was a I guess a
misunderstanding there the director was
under the impression initially it would
have be a text field that's a real
problem language of the bill says
approved security marking and putting a
small image or logo or even text applied
as an image there's no problem plenty of
room and she can do
it further
discussion seeing
none um I just have to say myself I
don't i' heard this several times I
paused I know this has been labeled as a
discriminatory bill but I generally do
not see it as that I mean if you read it
uh indicating citizenship or legal
residency and as you know there are
plenty of legal residents that can also
get not just regular driver's licenses
but real IDs too um as we know that the
driver's license began as a as a method
of indicating whether you can drive a
vehicle but we also all know that it's
morphed into a lot more than that it
essentially is our it's our
identification with a lot of pertinent
information on it this is just one more
piece of information it's not going to
be this scet letter or bold letters
across the front of it it's going to be
just a another bit of information on the
back side of the license so I will be
supporting this uh anybody
else seeing
n uh the motion on the floor is to pass
on coille
587 ask the clerk to call the rooll soon
she's
ready Vice chairman I think yes clerk
the clerk votes no representative Smith
yes representative Hill yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative bori yes
representative yes
representative yes representative
syes sorry
no Representative cleverer no
representative Fenton no representative
hit no representative Rich noesa
tki no representative
Fox no presentative
Stevens no
presentative no um chairman
Walsh uh
yes
no the motion
fails Mr chairman I'd like to offer
alternative motion
please head represent s yeah what was
the vote on the OTP
was it was nine 10 favor 10 opposed to
the okay I make a motion of uh uh to
pass represent tki seconds that
motion you mean
it I apologize I apologize my motion is
itl my goodness my day for mistakes
apparently it's the last few seconds
yeah I did thank you for correcting me
folks any further discussion
needed
seeing none the motion is now itl hille
587 chairman
gadney VES yes repr Smith
no Hill
no represent Aaron no representa anber
no bski no
representa
noo no representative
syes yes representative cever yes
representative Fenton yes Pickering yes
pres Rich yes pres
tki yes presentive Fox yes pres
Stevens yes
yes
no 10 to n the off to
pass itl itl sorry the itl was adopted
closes the EXA session on House Bill
587 one left few minutes House Bill
I'll do I'm doing The Minority Report on
that I got plenty of sheets here today
too yeah there there's two versions I
got one version it's fine I can fit it
on
good
Mr
chair that we just
did so the vote for itl was 10
yes no no the vote for itl was
9s oh I'm
sorry we ought to pass was n yes 10 wait
a minute can we repeat that the I
results the itl for
587 was 9 yes 10
no that's not correct it was 109 in
favor of itl
right no no let me start again on ought
to pass for 587
it was 10 no and nine yes that's
correct itl to itl the bill it was 10
yes n no right that's correct is not
going
on can't go on
consent most it can just be objected
to a long
day that's the half of
it it last
one last house
built
Mr J Aiden's trying to get back on he
lost
connection Aiden I just called him he
lost connection he's jumping back on
okay there he
is
we have everybody
back y
okay open the executive session on House
Bill
328 Relative to the application process
for driver's licenses relative to
privacy of Motor Vehicle Record
chaires representative pataro for a
motion thank you Mr chair I moved that
we itl House Bill
328 is there a
second gag seconds it here to speak your
motion
yes this the language in this bill and
what it attempts to do goes above and
beyond what the stated intent was from
everybody who signed up to speak and
everybody who submitted letters with
with there's a lot of testimony about
um uh undocumented people living in fear
but none of the testimony talk about
what was that issue was enforcing our
existing laws or um working with our
partners to enforce existing laws and I
just I am I really think think we need
to um take a step back here and think
about what the best ways to help our
undocumented Community is and I can tell
you that this bill is not so with that I
do move and I hope the rest of the
committee votes
I
discussion SES thank you Mr chairman
so the um the purpose of this bill at
the end of the day is to improve Public
Safety that is what this is all about it
is clear from testimony that we have
unfortunately undocumented persons
driving motor vehicles because it's the
only solution or choice that they have
and that is unfortunate because we have
no way of knowing if in fact they should
be driving whether they are
capable uh whether they are whether and
for whatever the reason why they might
not be capable we have no way of
determining that this bill attempts to
provide a
methodology which would allow the state
to determine if this person should be
driving or should not be driving and
that's through a fair system of testing
for uh written and reading comprehension
and also for a test for actual driving
ability
um this year we heard from a variety of
organizations that have been in support
of this bill those organizations ran the
gamut from the American friend service
committee to the ACLU to um various
immigrants
groups and
importantly recognizing the public saf
the aspect of this we also heard from
police Chiefs who say that this would be
a really important tool for them to uh
keep the motoring public safe and keep
people safe from a variety of different
reasons um we did in fact hear that um
more nearly 300 people signed in in
favor of this bill as opposed to iing it
only seven were opposed and they were
too
neutral for a transportation bill that
is that's the good news bad news about
uh online you know Blended me hearings
that we're having we actually got for
the first time a real opportunity to
hear and from people who are in support
of this billing when it shows the
widespread support and it R runs from a
bunch of different um people um the
other piece that didn't get an awful lot
of discussion but but only a minor part
but I think which is equally important
is that there's an economic aspect to
this in that insurance companies will
have the possibility of selling more
insurance that people will be better
able to keep their jobs and be safe that
way um and that is one of the these two
things Public Safety and um finding ways
to make um a better economy for everyone
in the state these are really Prime
directives for this committee um I know
there's a lot of emotion about why or
what this may or may not do um this bill
did have bipartisan support when it was
introduced this year I would urge my
colleagues on the um transportation
committee to take a careful look at
what this bill actually
does in terms of improving Public Safety
and I would appreciate that we uh do not
itl this bill so that another motion
could be introduced thank
you pres
pever thank you Mr chairman currently we
have thousands of people on the road who
are without
licenses which I find terribly
frightening in need to be tested they
need to be examined and need to be
licensed for all the reasons we've
discussed it is a public safety issue it
is a humanitarian issue there is no
other Transportation available to many
people undocumented is not
illegal and I think we need to have an
opportunity for them to be licensed for
our for our safety and and uh for the
benefit of all
thank
you representative
Stevens yes thank you Mr chair um
representative Cleaver touched on it a
little bit but what concerns me um be
besides the obvious Merit of the safety
and financial implications is the are
the social implications the ability of
people to be able to shop for food get
their children to Medical Care and
school Affairs and so forth so I am
going to um be in favor of um making a
motion for another opportunity to look
at this Bill thank
you representative Eric thank you Mr
chair I vote in favor of uh iing this
bill simply because the director of the
DMV um cited some opposition to it and
uh I think uh maybe at another time you
know we can consider something different
but uh as it is written it is it's just
not
ready thank you Mr
chairman um we received written
testimony via email I can't remember who
it was from but I'm sure that we would
be able to find it if we all went
through all that stuff that the issue
here is we have anywhere from the number
was 15,000 people let's say they're not
going away they're not leaving our state
they're here many of them had came here
um under certain visas that have lapsed
or um different situations where they
got caught in some kind of legal hole
that their legal status um was not
clarified and things are they're trying
to figure things out but the reality is
this is a humanitarian issue and this
is people who likely have children who
are US citizens um these people are
trying to feed their families they're
trying to work and contribute to society
and for us
to um not allow this one privilege which
17 other states give to undocumented
people to be able to be contributing
members of
society um I I I just think it's wrong
and I think that um we need to be able
to figure out a way for this group of
people um
to be able to contribute the way they
already are but to do so in a way that
does not put such an unfortunate
hardship on them in addition I thought
the testimony from um Chief carrian and
chief hodi about the role of law
enforcement and how they interact with
these Community um and the fact that
since they don't have a valid license
that affects way more than just if they
get in the car and drive or not this
affects every inter action they have
with the law enforcement Community
whether they're the victim of a crime
whether they have a concern whether they
they need some kind of assistance and um
I I just think that not moving forward
with um a solution for this community is
is just unfortunate and um I would hope
that we can overturn the motion on the
floor thank
you representative Cleveland yes sorry
for the repeat I just wanted to point
out what representative tersi already
said the impressive testimony from the
chiefs of police it would be very very
beneficial for our law enforcement
Community to have IDs on people and
driver's license not only on the roads
but other other purposes as they
testified very very important and
benefit beneficial for the uh law
enforcement group thanks
senori thank you Mr chairman you
know the issue I have with this bill
just right from the GetGo is for me
Crossing that first portal I mean we're
hearing illegals or a document whatever
you want to call um those people 14,000
in our testimony we're hearing that you
know they they're entitled to licenses
because they may be in between Visa they
have Visa issues well if I look at
14,000 I don't think all
14,000 have Visa issues which is causing
them to lose their license you know for
me when I when I read this legislation
the real hurdle is getting over that
first one where everyone's talking of
privilege in a right we talking about
people who are illegal or undocumented
and I don't feel that they have that
right or privilege and that I have to
vote itl on this legislation thank you
Mr chairman
representative
sites thank you Mr chairman
um I just I guess I would make the point
that we are in agreement with uh some of
the other Representatives here on the
transportation committee that driving is
a privilege we acknowledge that and and
accordingly as a privilege one should be
tested
and determined that they
are should be recipients of that
privilege um and that that is a key
point and I I I hope that folks will
remember that we are trying to make the
the privilege of driving and the ability
to test that they're driving safely is
Paramount to the the greater public
interest thank you J Smith
thank you Mr chairman sorry three points
um so one I apologize for missing
hearing on this one but the compelling
testimony I heard from the time we heard
this bill last was how careful folks are
because the worried about getting
stopped we had one gentleman testify
that he went as far as to install
mirrors in his garage so that when he's
going to leave he can just look in the
mirror and make sure that all the lights
on his car are working I want to ask how
many of you did that today cuz I didn't
um they they make sure that they don't
have anything dangling off the car they
do a whole walk around and I didn't do
that today did you I I'm guessing not so
I would balance the public safety issue
with the fact that we heard lots of
testimony that they're being more
careful than every single person on this
committee i' would be willing to wager
anyway um another thing that is missing
from the bill is I don't see any
references to the financial
responsibility was for having licenses
I've asked a few people if you don't
have a Social Security number can you
get SR22 insurance because there are
things you can do when you're driving
that could end up with you having to get
that that's an unanswered question in
the bill so that's another flaw and the
last one it's a driver's license not
identification right wrong like it or
not it's identification it's what people
accept and what we should have had was
was a way to have a separate license
that doesn't look like the one for
everybody else we could just get past
that whole issue but we heard testimony
last time also it must be the very same
license that you have in your wallet so
for these three reasons um I I can't
support the bill there are problems that
need to be worked
out any further
discussion seeing
none save my
voice and move right into the vote the
motion on the floor is itl on House Bill
328 ask the clerk to call roll as soon
as she's
ready Vice chair G yes CLK votes yes
Senor Smith yes representative Hill yes
representative Aaron yes representative
anber yes bsky yes representative Hara
yes
represa yes representative
sites mute
no
no no if you're asked for representative
sorry yes I did thank you representative
picking no representative
BR you're
muted Rich you're muted I'm saying it
louder though
no Representative tersi no
representative Fox no representative
Stevens
no
no wal
yes 10 to
NL is the recommendation so I closes the
executive session on Coast
bille so M Mr chairman y just um there
will be a Minority Report and probably a
floor fight on this I would expect
okay thank you sir are you gonna do that
are you gonna do a minority you got a
Minority Report coming I'm assuming yeah
I will um I'll either do it myself or
I'll find somebody who volunteers but
we'll we'll get it
done okay well I want to thank everybody
um got a lot of work done in a short
amount of time today was a long day and
I I truly truly appreciate us sticking
to it and finishing up for as much as
today hurts we're all going to
appreciate it for the next few weeks
so um I'll see you all soon there's any
unless there's any other questions I'm G
to uh save my voice and start getting to
all our committee reports we got quite a
few of them to review tonight so I'm
you're done not quite
yet Mr chairman y I was told that um and
and I have not done this myself but I've
been told because we had announced that
all um all roll calls would be all votes
would be roll call by by adjourning we
have to roll call out of here um as an
as taking the that's what I've been told
really yeah the first time I've heard it
in nine years I well they said because
of the emergency order is where it came
from
I didn't hear what he said motion he's
saying a motion he heard just recently
because of the emergency order that even
a motion to adjourn would require a
rooll
call what
to
no meeting in committee to adjourn you
declare that it's adjourned right
because because because we're doing our
work as either public hearing or an
executive session which that's already
been closed so so so this is saying the
the emergency order says all votes will
be so they were saying that this was a
vote to adjourn no there was yeah all
votes must be roll calls in a house of
committees there is no vote to
adjourn so okay he just says we're Jour
BS G that's it okay just like this we're
Jour
me